anybody who's speaking on house bill
zeros one
zero zero five
we you have any pink cards
send them up
okay
see if i got any message from the clerk
i don't
he might have put his files in there
anybody
get a message from the
clerk no but don't julie she's usually
here
candy
build copies
from last week they all came around
uh
did everybody in the in the
in the
second tier seats these are these drafts
oh yeah okay
there's draft and there's a
copy of the
oh that's what they think of me
uh they think that they slash slam that
down all the time
uh and the uh
there's there's a yes he has that uh now
that the draft is just on the inner
yeah the inner circle doesn't have it
sorry
this
i don't know if you leave them in the
corner right there that's way they can
pick them up
well i have a
message that i think is
i think is the clerk says she's going to
be 30 minutes late
we're going to have to start without her
and
she's going to have to play catch up
when she gets here
all right
i'm going to open the hearing on house
bill
or house bill 1005
relative to the creation of a low-grade
timber and wood emerging market
commission
and the chair recognizes representative
doug thomas
and you have uh you have written
testimony that you've
passed around
thank you uh chairman brazulo and
members of the resource recreation
committee here
uh my name is doug thomas i represent
londonderry rockingham five i'm also uh
the vice chair of the science tech
energy committee
which i find myself in an unusual
position this morning is usually bills
like this come to our committee
but um i just wanted to say that uh
we don't normally uh i don't normally
send bills for for commissions because
uh uh they're expensive and sometimes
they they seem to go on forever however
i'm introducing hp
1005 as a commission because it is very
important to our forest industry
and as you might know in the past
our forest industry which is great for
recreation and also with the fact that
our forests need to be healthy
has relied on
10 biomass plants to produce electricity
and do and use our
you know waste
wood eight of these ten plants have
closed the
the market
is expensive for producing energy
uh the forest people cannot find uh
adequate markets to
do with their trash wood which is
important like i said before for keeping
the forest healthy we are the second
new hampshire's
number two in the most forested state in
the country and our tourist industry
depends on good hiking and good forest
health so the purpose of submitting this
bill
is to establish a commission to find out
and talk about
other markets that might be
found for our wood industry
we know
that the
like i said before we know that the cost
of biomass is prohibitively expensive
which is why
i don't feel like we should be
um supporting the forest industry on the
backs of electric rate payers however i
do support the forest industry in that
we must find other ways for keeping this
industry going so we can protect our
forests our
tourist industry and of course to
protect the people that have jobs in it
right now
uh
i mentioned about the policies that led
to closing of these uh biomass plants
because the market is very very low now
for uh for keeping them open
and uh so this commission is is uh
designed to have experts come in from
from around the state
uh to discuss uh the various facets of
the timber industry and to help find any
emerging markets that might be uh useful
for our trash wood
just kind of an antidote while i was
away a couple months ago on a short trip
i ran into an individual from another
state that happened to be
the owner of a industry that uses trash
wood in his state and we had a very good
conversation so i know there's markets
out there that
that can use our trash wood other than
what we're using them for now and it's
up to this commission to find out what
they might be and how they could be used
for this
for our state
now the original bill that that you see
before you was supposed to have been
submitted last biennium but because of
the snafu and emails it it never got
approved so it carried over into this
year
since then we've come up with an
amendment that i think makes the bill
better it
specifically in part two of who would be
on on the commission
i think one of the important points i
want to bring out is that we we only
require one sandra to be on on this
commission uh usually that's all you're
gonna get anyway
and uh three house members but there are
other things in this amendment that i
would hope that this committee would
adopt there's another change to a date
on the final report
that says uh
2022 is the final report uh being being
a realist that's really not going to
happen during this coming campaign year
so i think my amendment will have a
change to 2023
now
as a final sum up because people will
come
after me
to discuss the possibilities of what
could happen to our emerging market for
wood industry i just want to say that i
grew up upstate new hampshire in the
town of warford and
i grew up with my friends parents were
loggers they did a lot of industry there
and i
i also uh recognized that in my own town
of londonderry we have an industry uh
i think it's melting caterpillar that is
very heavily involved with the wood
industry so this this issue is not
specific to one area or one town it
affects the entire state
either indirectly or directly
so
i would appreciate consideration of hp
108 10 1 0 0 8
and
five i mean and so
i'm going to leave any questions to come
up for people behind me
and uh know the fact that we are working
on this amendment
uh to make this bill even better so with
that i will close mr chairman and i hope
i stay within my three minutes
thank you that that's fine uh i
will take some questions i'll ask but i
think most will be answered by
others
uh that's true if you have a general
question uh i'll answer one or two but
if there's anything involving the
technical aspects i i have at least
three or four people behind me that that
can speak to it okay i just have one
question the
the amendment that you submitted is a
draft only and there will be a
forthcoming
amendment with with some additional
information absolutely uh it's just
timing be what it is we we know we're
going to be doing this one and i think
we're going to make a few more changes
to boots so we will be submitting okay
commandment
representative egan for a question thank
you mr chair thank you represent for
taking my question are you aware that
new hampshire has a new hampshire canada
trade council and therefore when you're
suggesting your senators or
representatives knowing the amount of
lumber trade that goes on between new
hampshire and quebec and canada it might
be good to look at those representatives
that have a better understanding of
sort of the import export market i just
want to make sure you were aware of that
organization has actually run through
the secretary of state's office here in
the state i say so because i'm actually
a mental but it might be worthwhile when
you're
searching out your representatives and
senators to serve on this commission i
think it's a great idea and i would
recommend so were you that's the
question is were you aware that we
actually have a
legislative group that works with canada
on trade issues
thank you for the question yes i am
aware of that in fact i
i believe one of the representatives
that sits on my committee
i think is a member of of that or is
associated with the trade industry in
one way or the other and i am looking at
that representative as possibly to
volunteer to be on this commission so
yes i am aware of that
simple follow-up could i who
is that
uh well uh normally don't
divulge
representative names in a testimony but
if uh if if if you wish uh i i believe
that representative is a representative
murderer from uh lancaster work with him
oh lancaster yeah work with him closely
on the council and um
so thank you yes all right thank you for
it was sort of a informational question
so thank you mr chair for indulging me
thank you uh just just a reminder for
everyone the this
hearing is uh on you going on youtube so
what you say
is not necessarily stay in the stay in
this room or las vegas so
thank you very much
oh you have a question i'm sorry
represent
hey
uh remember i got eight more i got eight
more uh i just want to let you know i
have eight more
all cards represent representative cohen
and representative smith
oh yes you're fine okay yes um thank you
for taking my question yeah i think the
uh i have a question i like the
amendment the amendment takes the
original bill that even tightens it up a
little bit more especially when you
added somebody from natural and cultural
resources to help resolve the problem
i'm wondering in the next amendment
version if there'll be anything on a
goal that will look at some of the
alternatives that the commission comes
out with and the effect on new
hampshire's environment as well
i don't know if that's your intent or
not
i'll certainly take that under
advisement and talk to my
people that are that are more involved
with with that industry and i'm sure we
can work something in there if it's
going to help out the forest
industry yeah thank you mr taran thank
you representative for taking my
question uh in the amendment i i really
like the new makeup of the uh
commission
um by the way but um i did notice that
you went from having the commission
extend to 2025 to end in 2022
and just wanted to ask you if you
thought that was going to be enough time
if you have commitments from people to
say yes we can get this done or
um i um i believe that
my final report
that's in the amendment says 2022
correct and i uh previously mentioned
that that would be one of the changes
that would come out in a in my amendment
because
with the season coming the way it is
there is there wouldn't be enough time
to have a final report by 2022 so i'm
going to recommend that we have it at
least 2023
so it gives them more time to get all
the experts together and have a good
final report my intent is though once
this commission does its job that it
would cease and desist
because i don't like
never-ending commissions
but i i would expect them to come up
with a final report from which we can go
on from there great thank you good to
hear that
i will remind the representatives that
the final amendment is what we put out
uh it'll come here
but we can still change it so
there may be discussion on that final
amendment as well here
thank you
uh call
jason stock representing the new
hampshire timberland
timberland owners association
you
yeah
you might as well put that in the
amendment too
bring back bring lots of stuff to the
hearings
you
representative egan thank you very much
for for
for coming on to this committee
that's right
why don't uh why don't you start the
representative
with me
okay
um well good morning uh for the record
my name is jason stock i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire timberland
owners association
and uh i want to thank you for the
opportunity to come and testify this
morning on house bill
1005.
um
the new hampshire tribulators
association we represent timberland
owners but we also represent the forest
products industry that's the entire
supply chain from stump to sheet of
paper
to
the two by four that comes out the back
end of a sawmill and so
um come here today to support the bill
and we support the amendment that
representative thomas has has moved also
um
as as he mentioned in his testimony
a lot of folks don't realize this we're
the second most forested state in the
nation behind maine as a percent of land
mass and
forests really define our state and kind
of
define our
and also
define us culturally but also
economically
our forest products industry is a 2.5
billion dollar industry
that's direct and indirect so that's
people actually out in the woods or in
the sawmills it's also the support
industries like milton cat caterpillar
that sell
sell the skitter sell the harvester to
the logger
so it's it's a significant part of the
forest products industry and
a lot of people don't realize that
because we don't have a big factory
sitting next to interstate 93 all our
work happens out in the woods
and at sawmills throughout the state
um i'm providing you
three reports
the first is the economic
analysis done by unh cooperative
extension
that highlights the 2.5 billion dollars
breaks it down by sector
also talks about the number of jobs
12 800 that this industry supports
across the state
so you have that report from unh
cooperative extension it's the economic
uh the economic analysis report
um
so the
the the entire industry though is
it derives its existence on trees on
timberland
um
as i mentioned we're the second most
forested state
um
and
timber harvesting occurs on an annual
basis when you look at timber tax data
we have about 2500 timber harvests that
occur across the state of new hampshire
and they occur in almost every town
it sees it a timber harvest across the
state um even
places like manchester auburn and even
on on the seacoast there is there is
timber harvesting activity
um
one of the
one of the unfortunate things is due to
the nature of our timber
in soils and climate a lot of our wood
is considered low grade
when i say considered low grade that's
wood that's in incapable of producing
lumber
traditionally that's gone into paper
making
but also biomass power has been also a
big part of that
again looking at department of revenue
timber tax data
on average
in 2020
the state about 2.5 million tons of wood
was harvested in new hampshire this is
all products all species all grades so
that's
and this is commercial so this isn't me
going out back on the back 40 and
cutting firewood for my wood stove this
is
this is wood that's cut for sawmill
production it's cut and hauled to paper
mills but it's also firewood that's cut
and called to a processing facility that
winds up selling it at your local
convenience store or at a camp at a
state campground so 2.5 million tons
is what
is produced
from our forest every year
the the biomass plants
that representative thomas
mentioned
those represented about a million tons
of low-grade wood consumption so to put
things in perspective
to have
about a million tons out of a two-point
million ton market just kind of stop
is pretty dramatic and it has sent a
tremendous ripple through the industry
exacerbating this
in i think it was 2020 april 15 tax day
2020 there's a paper mill in j maine
that literally blew up
um that pulp and paper mill
um the digester blew up it was pretty
extraordinary there's youtube videos on
it
but that mill also re represented they
they drew fiber
low-grade wood out of new hampshire
and so to kind of quantify this
last year senator bradley had asked
um it asked to nhtoa to put together a
report to kind of quantify what it
what's going on with low-grade wood
markets and so in your packet is a
second report that we pulled together
that kind of quantifies this it looks at
the biomass plants
but it also looks at the at the paper
mill
and you'll see on the the second page
again
you know the the six power plants 1.2
million
1.25 million tons
and then we also incorporate
later on in the report some of the
impacts from that from the
from the paper mill
so
again what this all means is the
industry has seen tremendous contraction
in the market
um and the ripple effect has been pretty
extraordinary as is a timberland owner
two-thirds of what is growing on my
property is considered low-grade what do
i do with it
i you know if i hire a logger to come
and cut my you know do a thinning on my
property or do some management he looks
at my woodlot and says well i can take
that tree or that tree but the rest i'm
not sure i can what am i going to do
with it
traditionally they would be chipped or
would be sent to a paper mill
so it's created a management and as the
resources committee the state's forest
resource it's affecting the the state's
forest resource we've seen the logging
capacity contract
we've also seen
timber sales uh timber sales start the
number of december sales contract
talking to landowners and land managers
there are instances where timberland
they just can't
literally can't harvest it why because
there's not enough higher quality wood
to economically justify entering that
property
so it's affecting the the you know the
forest resource
and so
the second piece and the kind of the the
third trickle down you have the
landowner you have the logger trying to
operate on on a pretty slim margin as it
is but the third is kind of this sawmill
piece you say well how does this affect
sawmills they use higher grade lumber or
higher grade timber well because that
logger that logging capacity is
contracted
um
the number of saw logs are getting cut
has also diminished and so what we're
seeing is sawmills struggling to get
enough
timber to feed their mill
a logging company that maybe had two or
three crews before has one so not only
are they producing less low grade
they're also producing fewer saw logs so
that same company now
so that sawmill now has to has to try to
attract more loggers
and geographically go further outside
the outside the state to try to attract
wood
so it's increased cost for them
the other thing is sawmills take round
logs and make square lumber they chip
those slabs
what do you do with that chipwood in the
days of old they used to take slabs and
literally pile them up out behind the
sawmill
friday night they had these metal
teepees friday night they'd throw a
match on it they'd come in sunday or
monday morning and there'd be a pile of
ashes and they'd say let's get some boys
we're done
can't do that anymore so those chips
those slabs are now chipped
and they go to they've traditionally
gone to biomass markets or pulp and
paper
again
talking to sawmills and you'll hear from
one today
the number of markets is greatly reduced
increasing cost and really starting to
flip what was once considered an asset
clean clean mill chips now into a
liability
um and then the third piece the other
piece for sawmills is kind of long
term if
looking out i'm a sawmill i'm looking
out 20 i'm making capital investments
today that i'm looking at a 15 20 year
payback
and i want to make sure that there's a
timber resource that can feed my mill i
want to make sure that people are
performing sustainable good forestry
today
that can feed my mill 15 20 years from
now if there aren't markets for this
low-grade
low-grade timber that makes that
sustainable
forest improvement work on the land
difficult
and so they're looking at that saying
all right i need to be thinking long
term
on kind of future wood quality
so for all those reasons um and i think
i exceeded my my my time limit
um
but i i wanted to kind of lay this out
to explain to you that we're looking at
an
environmental kind of resource issue and
it was a great question about the
environmental piece we're looking at
environment resources but we're also
looking at an economics piece
and so this
this re this commission is very timely
we have neighboring states already ahead
of the curve on us trying to do this
type of work
and it would be great to have new
hampshire
follow suit and work on this
so for that i i'd ask that you support
house bill
1005 and the the proposed amendment i'd
be happy to answer any questions
questions from the committee
representative smith thank you mr chair
and thank you mr stock for taking my
question i know that a number of our
county
complexes grafton in particular
use biomass to provide power to their
correctional facility nursing home
administrative building whatever
the amount that is used by these
individual
uh small biomass
energy energy facilities how does that
compare to what we've lost in biomass
since the changes that came down a
couple of years ago
sure
thank you for your question and it's
it's a good question
it's it's orders of magnitude difference
um when you look at a biomass power
plant that was consuming literally
hundreds of thousands of tons and county
complexes
i in my our community we have a school
district that uses wood chips to heat
its facilities
you know they're using thousands
thousands of tons versus hundreds of
thousands of tons so although it helps
and we love
any market that we can have
it's just you know we would need a lot
of county complexes
and a lot of school districts to make up
the hundreds of thousands or the the 1.2
million that's
that we had
surveyed
thank you
representative gould
for our question
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
for taking my question uh
where do we get our paper now
so there are paper mills still operating
um
there are paper mills that are that are
still operating in
in new england there's also a lot of
paper being made offshore
as well
right now
in
new england
in in
in terms of pulp making paper from wood
chips
directly from wood chips there's a paper
mill in glens falls new york there's one
in rumford maine and there are several
in in northern maine as well
again the thing to keep in mind is that
wood chips are a commodity so to put a
wood chip on a truck
you know the economics to haul it
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
miles aren't there
there are paper mills such as monadnock
paper down in the antrum area they make
paper but they purchase pulp already
pre-processed
um that's made you know at other paper
mills um based on their paper making
recipe
so for us you know it really comes down
to the the for for forest management
where are the pulp mills
and right now we have one in glens falls
we have one in uh skowhegan maine we
have a third
and the third important one is in
rumford maine
that answer your question
uh any other questions from members of
the committee seeing
representative health
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm um
relatively new to this
concept
um
is this primarily
private industry and we're just trying
to figure out better ways for them to be
able to perform their
if
sure it's a half question but
yeah thank you for thank you for the
question in other words this is not like
a government
exactly and i i should probably um i
probably should have said that it
what we're looking at is a study to look
at how can we attract private capital
private investment in the state
maine is already kind of down this path
they have it's called the forest
opportunity road map for maine
we're looking at trying to do something
in new hampshire as well this is really
kind of part of that effort but where
are there where are there opportunities
to attract businesses to new hampshire
that could utilize this low-grade timber
there are um
there are of course
we always know about we all know about
wood pellets is one albeit it's still
pretty small
there are different other other
different products such as biochar and
then also liquid chemicals as well
different types of
liquid biodiesel things of that and so
the function of this commission and why
it's important to have these additional
folks on it is to bring that expertise
to bear and say all right what's out
there
what can we do to attract this
investment in new hampshire
because we get an economic impact but we
also get a resource management impact
thank you
representative harvey golia
thank you mr chair
um could we possibly take this
road map from you know the studies that
have been done in maine and sort of
piggyback on that would that be a more
direct method
that's a great great question we can to
some extent and another speaker can
speak to it the thing to recall is that
in maine there's a tremendous spruce fir
forest spruce for a resource that isn't
i mean we do have spruce for
in higher elevations and in coast county
but our forest types are slightly
different
in in many respects and so there are
some there's some crossover and a future
speaker today can kind of speak to that
but it's not a one-to-one to say ah
let's grab their report and let's just
do it because there are some there's
also some other kind of infrastructure
differences as well in terms of
how new hampshire's laid out and some
real advantages that we have that they
don't have there so there's some things
we should
it all merits a commission taking a look
at it and certainly drawing from what
others have done
for a follow-up
they
i'm not sure if they have a true
commission other than they have this
forest opportunity roadmap which brings
in
kind of what we're trying to do here
with academia
industry folks landowners etc and again
i'm i know and
i know about the project i've read about
it
there are others that will speak today
that are
more directly engaged in that project to
get into how mechanically it was
structured
seeing no further questions from members
of the committee
thank you very much thank you
jared calls
robert clegg for biotech
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
robert clegg i represent biotechnology
innovation organization
and um we're here to um
submit testimony in favor of this bill
because we think that we can provide
um some form of of assistance in getting
the bigger
companies in
bio is a
trade group representing more than 1100
biotechnology
companies some academic institutions
and in new hampshire
we have
there are 413 entities employing
6286 people
and
the enactment of hb105
i'm sorry one zero zero five would help
both of those numbers
we're here to talk about wood chips and
sawdust that can be converted to
renewable chemicals
which would be used to replace petroleum
to make containers packaging
rubber and various consumer industrial
products
specifically renewable chemical
chemicals sourced from woody biomass
could already be in your shampoo your
hand lotion the clothes you wear could
even be woven from fabric derived from
wood
and as such bio would like to be part of
this commission
to to assist in bringing in the
companies that would assist us in in
another form beyond just burning
uh mr chairman in in light of the fact
that we're running behind
i i left one copy and i'll leave another
um but we would be available to to work
with everybody i've talked to some of
the people in the industry
they seem to be in favor of of adding
biotechnology to the to the commission
and again the previous speaker spoke
about
bringing in people who have
the ability to invest in new hampshire
i believe this group could help us
i'll answer any questions if you have
any
any questions from members of the
members of the committee
seeing none thank you very much
the chair calls joe carrier
representing hhp
what does hhp stand for
uh it
started off uh as a henniker hardwood
and pallet and currently legally it
stands for hhp but we're a hardwood
sawmill located right down the road in
henniker new hampshire that's that's
fine yeah
and yeah so
my name is is joe carrier
i'm here today to show my support for
uh
hb1005
um
in addition to that i do support the
proposed amendments
i do feel that this is a timely issue
that should be addressed
you know fairly quickly
just to give you guys a little bit of a
background about
hhp we are also affiliated with
four other forestry locations in the
state all owned by some of the same
owners of hhp
rj chipping is an example they're
located in shelburne new hampshire
milan lumber
which is a mile in new hampshire
pr russell which is in brentwood new
hampshire
and ossipee chipping which is in austria
new hampshire
out of all those locations that i just
mentioned
there is one that's currently not
running
due to the low-grade
market situation that we have
circling back to
specifics about hhp
i am general manager of hhp i'm not sure
if i mention that
but we employ 80 people
we have a first shift in second shift
we have uh let's see here
yeah as far as as far as the uh you know
purchasing of uh forest products uh we
purchase annually 56 000 tons of pulp a
year uh which will be going into the
paper industry
we also purchase
roughly 13 and a half million board feet
of logs a year
and through that procurement process we
have about 85
suppliers that bring us those products
and lastly about hhp you know we over
the next five years we plan on
making a capital investment of about 18
million
providing that you know everything goes
well within the next five years
um
to talk about how
biomass affects
hhp and our suppliers
as jason alluded to
you know we we are hardwood sawmill so
we technically
buy high grade but as a result of sawing
sawing that high grade
there's a byproduct
that goes into the low grade markets um
this we
our our
byproducts equates to about roughly 25
loads a week i would say
and for
many of those
products which is sawdust chips bark
that sort of thing
there's really just one market
for many of those products
so it's a it's a tough situation uh for
us you know if
if anything that happened to any of
those current markets i'm not sure
exactly what we would do just to paint
the picture
as far as how biomass affects our
procurement process
in low grade uh our our bloggers really
rely on
this low-grade market um you know to be
economically viable
and also to do an adequate um harvesting
job you know for for landowners
and you know as jason said
uh not only have we lost many you know
loggers due to the low grade situation
but they're less effective they can't
produce as quickly
there's logistical challenges they in
money's tied up and all those sort of
things so it's it's been
very very tough uh i'm sure you've heard
from many other industries that you know
the the help and
um is is a is a challenge for us the
help certainly is but the second biggest
one is is procurement
and we don't really see that changing
for
a really long time you know if if the
markets don't change
um
yeah and i guess if you guys have any
questions i'll be willing to answer any
questions from members of the committee
representative post
thank you for taking my um
thank you for allowing me to speak mr
chair and thank you for being here today
um you indicated that you have 85
different suppliers where are they
coming from
primarily i'd say
some are coming from
massachusetts vermont but primarily i'd
say 95 is within a small radius of our
mill
any other questions from
from the committee
if not thank you very much
excellent thank you
a chair called charles levesque from
antrim
representing himself
for three minutes
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i'm charlie levesque
i live in antrim new hampshire
and i'm president of a consulting firm
that's about 30 years old called
innovative natural resource solutions
we have our corporate office here in new
hampshire we also have an office in
maine
i'm here in strong support of hb 1005
and the amendment i just got to see the
amendment this morning
it's a critical time and i know that the
legislature often frowns on commissions
and study committees but i remind you
things like the renewable portfolio
standard and lchip came out of study
committees or commissions so sometimes
really important things can come out of
them so i urge you to to support it for
that reason
jason stock did a great job explaining
what the problem is so this problem is
not only in new hampshire it's across
the region
and uh the new england region has lost
over 20 percent of its low-grade markets
over the last few years and it's 40
percent loss in new hampshire as jason
said so when you lose 40 percent of the
market for a particular industry it's a
very serious problem and and to date
unfortunately even though the sununu
administration has known about this
problem for a number of years they
really haven't done anything on it and i
think that's why there's a need for
a commission coming out of the
legislature
hopefully the administration will
participate if you pass this bill but
it's really essential
i have some knowledge on what's going on
in surrounding states to your questions
around the four main effort but vermont
has also stepped up to the plate about
five years ago creating a working lands
initiative fund which is a general fund
appropriation that happens every year
and it's for the forest products
industry and also for the agricultural
industry and a lot has happened with
that that's how they stepped up to the
plate to try to address some of these
problems
in maine uh the problem
was not the biomass plants although
that's been part of a problem there the
problem there was a closure of pulp
mills
if you remember if you've been around
here we used to have two pulp mills in
new hampshire we had one in berlin we
had in one in groveton they are long
gone so we're not talking about pulp
mills and we know we're not going to
revive the biomass power plants although
we hope we can maintain the two that are
largely operating at this point we need
to find solutions elsewhere and that's
what this work would would be about in
maine it happened in a major way about
four years ago when
senator angus king
basically brought a swat team from the
u.s department of commerce to the state
of maine to look at the problem they
just had several closures of pulp mills
at the time
and coming out of that is this forced
opportunity roadmap initiative which is
on its fourth year now working uh
they've been funded with a lot of
federal dollars and some state dollars
in foundation funding but it's been a
huge organization that the
administration the legislative branch
the private sector has been behind and
they've already seen fruits they've got
a
brand new
wood-based cellulose insulation plant
being constructed as we speak in a
former former site of a pulp mill
and there's also a brand new company
that is looking to commercialize biochar
they are all coming out of this effort
so the point of that is
when you come together as a state both
as state government working with the
private sector as a commission would
some good things could come out of it
and we've got a good example that's
going on next door uh in maine and so uh
our company uh is uh involved in helping
the forest products industry in
renewable energy uh i'm also the
executive director of a small non-profit
called the northeast state foresters
association
patrick hackley who is your director of
the division of force the lands he and
his colleagues in the northeast are part
of this little non-profit and work
together and they've identified this
problem region-wide as a major problem
for forestry in the forest products
industry so i've got a lot of expertise
our firm does and if this commission
gets created we'll certainly be willing
to be there and volunteer to help it out
uh and uh at that at that given the time
uh i'd uh gladly answer any questions
but uh i'm here to help and and
hopefully uh you will uh vote to pass
this uh this bill thank you
any questions from members of the
committee representative egan
thank you mr chair thank you sir for
taking my question um are you aware of a
forest products accelerator that's based
that's recently been created and based
at northern vermont university in linden
that's focused on vermont's effort to
create new industry in the in the forest
forestry world as well work with the
state of new hampshire
yes i am very well well aware of that
that that's come out of a federal grant
from the usda forest service that
project uh it's a real micro project
it's not the kind of project uh that's
going to address the big problems that
we have although it's a good thing and
anything that we can do but it's a very
small project good project and thank you
for the question
quick follow-up for a follow-up those
are the kind of things that this you
would hope this commission would look
into whether it's due to working with
universities federal grants and the idea
that looking at
what are new innovative ways to make
wastewood be practical to our society
yes that's correct representative we
need we need a kind of an all hands on
deck approach and even small operations
like they're trying to do there should
be part of this it really should be
looking at every opportunity thank you
any other questions members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr chairman
matt leahy from the forest society
uh good morning thank you mr chairman
i'm matt leahy i'm the public policy
director for the forest society
we are a statewide land trust based here
in concord um
you know jason and charlie and
representative thomas laid out
really the reasons why this commission
is important and certainly if you look
at the
findings and purpose
in the bill
that really spells out
the issue and the challenge very well i
would just add one point i know
you're running behind but
um you know when we talk about
you know the forest products industry
and you know the stresses that they're
facing you know ultimately
um you know we should keep in mind that
almost or a little over 70 percent of
the forced
land in new hampshire is privately owned
private landowners you know it's not the
federal government or the state
government it's private landowners so
you know we um
think it's important to you know find
ways
you know to help those landowners keep
their forests as forests i mean that's
sort of our ultimate goal
so you know and for that reason we think
this commission is very important to
kind of get us you know to that ultimate
goal so um that's why we support it um
and thank you for your time
any questions for mr lee
seeing none thank you very much
linda brownson
from wentworth representing
herself
and the new hampshire timber owners
association
and you're from wentworth new hampshire
good morning members house members
members of committee thank you for uh
giving me the opportunity if you don't
mind with your permission i'm going to
remove my mass to speak right ahead so
that
so i don't sound so muffled
uh thank you for letting me speak to you
today
yes i am linda brownstone of grafton
county and uh
i am a timberland owner i own and manage
200 acres in the western foothills of
the white mountains
uh in wilm in wentworth and i manage for
wildlife and for forest health
i also represent 12 states in the
northeast region
for the executive board of the national
association of conservation districts
and i'm also president of the new
hampshire timberland owners association
and i'm here today in strong support of
the house bill 1005
as well as the amendment especially with
the amendment
and
[Music]
so i'm here to speak on that
the single biggest issue facing
timberland owners like myself
is the lack of low-grade wood markets
because low-grade markets are the
underpinning of sustainable forest
forestry and forest management
and uh it provides also the
the economic means for landowners
to
remove dead and decaying trees for
forest health
to remove those trees for uh that are
dying because they've been
infected with pathogens or are invasive
species like the emerald ash borer which
is now spread to nine out of ten of our
counties
it also enables the landowner to
practice
timber stand improvement for one thing
which i do
and that is to rehabilitate degraded
hardwood stands
and to replace you know
less desirable species with
better species for timber and for
wildlife
and also uh in my case to create and
maintain
trails for uh
hiking and skiing and
things like that recreational pursuits
the contraction of the low-grade wood
markets in this state
is an opportunity
you know with the biomass plant closures
which you're all familiar with i'm sure
and also the
the loss of a
major pulp mill in j maine
um it provides the opportunity for this
bill
to actually
help
attract
capital investment private investment to
solve some of these emerging
and new wood markets
and it also sends i think a positive
message
that new hampshire cares about this
issue
and that they they want to attract
private investment
to
help these markets low-grade wood
markets and the emerging in new markets
some of these markets are
things you may already have heard about
like wood cellulose insulation
bio
fuels
biochar bio oils
biochar for example one of my favorite
that i'm following a lot is they they
give value to those dead trees and
biomass in the forest
and they reduce
carbon
carbon co2 emissions from the from our
environment
and
they also if used as a soil amendment
they um
they promote soil health healthy soils
for agriculture and for forest land
and they have outstanding
attributes for
absorbing nutrients
and agricultural chemicals so they
reduce runoff into streams and so on
and this particular area is exploding
right now and they're just looking for
places to go to and then i think we
should be one of them
um so
this bill
also
as proposed this commission as proposed
could
help inform
policies and programs that are really
badly needed right now
to address
these low-grade wood markets
and and to serve
the the the industry that might come in
and that will benefit all of us
and also the environment
so thank you very much for your
attention and i
i
support this bill and and
can answer any questions you might have
any questions from members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh mr robert birdie
is that
or three to five minutes
support of the bill
with an amendment
i have instructions here
good morning
my name's bob berdy i am a forester
i guess somewhat retired but i'm still
active
i'm also a procurement agent for
low-grade fuels for
one of the existing power plants in new
hampshire and also service
several schools holding the school
plymouth high school grafton county
and a few other businesses
i'm here to probably give you some
historical background
on
low-grade markets and the importance
to the state and to this wonderful
natural resource that we have
i'm going to go back in time into the
60s and 70s when i began my career
i bought a woodlot when i was
a
sophomore in high school i still own
that woodlot and in fact i'm going to be
doing a timber harvest on that
i've owned that lot for almost 60 years
and i hope to pass that on to my
grandson
when i bought that property
it had been cut over probably 15 years
before there was still a viable timber
stand on it a lot of old grade wood
and is
so i took an axe and i went in and
girdled 38 acres
getting rid of the low-grade trees
i got some compensation from the federal
government for doing that
and since that time i've had two timber
harvest and this will be my third
but the important at that time there
really wasn't much of a markets for many
of the trees that were on the forest
it's a hardwood forest
and
i
griddled uh
some soft maple and
other trees but i saved some of those
soft maples and those are going to be
cut
in in the timber operation and at that
time as i said there was no market for
soft maple
but today there is a very nice market
for soft maple so over time
i was able to to uh build the uh
the forest and
get the results of the change in the
marketplace
but i i want to talk a little bit about
the importance of
markets in low-grade markets i travel a
lot in in the west
midwest i'm in the mountain west
states like colorado wyoming montana
idaho western south dakota and northern
utah
and when i first started going out there
in the mid 70s it was a viable forest
industry
um
at that time there was a lot of concerns
about overcutting and road building on
national forest land and most of the
west is national forest
and there was a movement and it was
quite successful in shutting down
harvesting on the timber areas in in the
western side of our country
and
about ten years ago
i was coming from uh wyoming down into
colorado and came through the uh i
believe it was the
white river national forest
uh just north of uh steamboat springs
and uh
my wife and i were traveling and i said
you can't i can't believe what i'm
seeing there's just hundreds of
thousands of acres of dead lodgepole
pine
and i stopped at the ranger station
and i went in and i said how can you let
this happen he says we have no markets
they have been successful in shutting
down
harvesting on the
on the national forest by different acts
of congress
recently if you follow the news
uh i think it was last year that forest
burnt up
and over that period of time
we put
thousands and thousands and hundreds of
thousands of tons of co2 back into the
atmosphere
not only do we do that
and add to climate change but we also
destroyed a forest
that takes in
co2
and emits
oxygen so
the lack of of of being able to harvest
your forest in the west has had dramatic
effect and we can talk about climate
change but a well-managed forest
the amount of
forest fires that have happened out
there would not have happened
because they just did not have the
markets to go in and harvest this timber
so
i also
uh when i began my career in forestry
excuse me sir uh
well could you uh be more specific to
the bill your testimony i'm sorry could
you be more specific uh with your
testimony to the bill itself
uh i'm trying to build to the point of
of the importance of low-grade markets
and and how it affects
the
the the management of our forest
and without market conditions and and
that's the point of time i don't want to
get into an argument with you it's just
that
you do set up for three to five minutes
so
i i will try to flip it up please thank
you so i will say that in in my
association with
managing forest in new hampshire and in
the northeast
that
the importance of markets and the health
of our forest is essential and this bill
i think helps resolve that
today there are
technologies
and i think others have talked to it
that will
take in the slow grade market i think
this study
will help get us there
i think the one issue that
needs to be addressed as you go forward
with it is to make sure that there's the
economic
incentives for people to be able to
do
to
get the technologies working but they
are they do exist and there are others
that have expressed what they are and i
hope we go forward with that
well thank you
thank you is there any questions
from members of the committee
seeing none thank you very much
last
card is
griffin roberge
speaking for the
new hampshire
energy department
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is griffin roberge and
i'm from the new hampshire department of
energy
the department doesn't take a position
on the bill we just wanted to offer a
slight technical amendment to page 1
line 28
it requires that the director of the
department of energy is an appointed
member to the commission um there are a
number of directors respectfully in the
department of energy
the
department would prefer
if the committee amended the bill to say
the commissioner of the department of
energy or designee
beyond that that is really all i had to
offer
respectfully as a former senate staffer
i'd just like to point out that
um i imagine on lines 25 and 26 three
members of the senate might run into a
little bit of a
a hill in the senate so just flagging
that for
everybody's consideration other than
that uh willing to take any questions
duly noted
my only um question is uh
could you put that uh your
recommendation in writing i could i
could certainly email you and
make certain representative thomas has a
copy of it
any other questions
any other questions from uh
i'm going against protocol
congratulations
thank you very much representative
any other questions from members of the
committee there being none
thank you very much thank you
there being no other speakers
i will call the hearing on house bill
closed
and i will open
the
hearing on house bill
1555 fn
repealing the permit required for fires
and campgrounds
i apologize for running late it seems
that
in the old days commissions and
committees were done in 15 minutes
and those have been our two biggest ones
over the
last two hearings
of time
we have
chair recognizers
representative burke
thank you
mr chairman
i am
representative john burt i represent
goffstown where and deerin
in district 39 of hillsboro
mr chairman and fine committee members
this is a real simple
and i do mean simple bill
i hope you will pass it as
we are talking just about a small
campfire on your private property in
your backyard with your grandkids or
your or your children that's all this
does
so if you go to home depot
lowell's
albins the local hardware store
and buy one of those little tin buckets
that you can put your campfire in
the majority of people do not understand
you have to get permission from the
government to light that on your private
property in your backyard with your
grandkids
because this is the third time that i've
tried to pass this bill so i'm hoping
the third time is the charm
this does not repeal
anything bigger than 24 inches or even
you know about that size
so if you want to have a big barn about
a bonfire in the backyard or on your
field or anywheres else you still have
to get permission
now the last couple hearings especially
the first hearing i sat on the criminal
justice committee and tried to pass this
not criminal justice i'm sorry it was um
municipal
in county government is that where the
back in 2010 when this bill about 11
when this bill first came through
according to the chiefs of police
they estimate 70 to 75 of not police
fire chiefs
they estimate 70 to 75 percent of people
do not get a permit
you know that's just a guess but that's
what they said
because really most people don't realize
you're supposed to get one
what i look at is new york state
repealed theirs several years ago
and i'm looking at if new york will do
it new hampshire definitely should
and if you noticed i don't know if any
of you have driven over to new york it's
been about four years since they
repealed this camp fire permit so if you
have a big camp you know a big bonfire
you still have to get a permit from your
local fire department
campfires you don't in new york and if
anybody's driven through new york in the
last four or five years when they passed
this
it's still standing
it's not burnt down because that's what
you're going to hear from the people
behind me if they come up and testify
that if we pass this the whole state of
new hampshire is going to be gone
because it will burn down
i trust my neighbors with their
campfires
now the big giant fire that they have
occasionally yeah okay maybe the fire
department should know
just in case
but they still haven't burnt my house
down so i'm happy
but those little campfires when they
have their little daughter out there my
neighbor
it isn't going to get away from them
because it's in one of those 10 things
you know they're very good just like i
am just like you guys are just like
everybody is
that's all this repeals
now you're also going to hear about the
fire stands
you know up north i i don't know if we
have any down this way but i know up
north they have a few fire stands up by
the lake region i think there's one and
what they do is they look out and look
for fires so that way and dry
excuse me so during dry times they can
say oh there's a fire over there and
they can look at their map and then
they'll call the fire department and
they'll somebody will run over there and
say hey what's going on
well that's usually with a big bonfire
these little fires
in
my neighborhood
and from what i when i talk to my
friends in their neighborhoods is mostly
at night
so these fire stations aren't going to
see them anyways
and i'm not sure if you could see a
small campfire you know 12 15 inches
fire
you know a couple miles away it's only
the big ones
so you will hear about that
now getting toward the end
i'm sure you are aware that
we have hot dog day
and that's where this came from
i was a brand new rep got on the house
floor and i told everybody if you vote
with me
i'll give you a hot dog
and have a campfire without a permit
well i realize you can't bribe reps
so i learned something that day that i
can't bribe you so i won't
but since then i invite everybody to hot
dog day
and when we have that campfire permit
outside out in the front of the new
hampshire state house
it is
without a permit
i have never got a permit because we
don't need one here
now i did have some fights with the city
but since then we have patched up and
now we hug and we're good friends
so the city understands that i'm not
getting a permit for hot dog day
matter of fact i even invite them over
and they come
so everything's going to be okay if this
passes
i'll state my name on that
so i want to go back to again and
to new york
if new york state
the city of
albany and
the good reps there and the senators and
the governor can say you know what we
need to get rid of it there
we really got to get rid of it in new
hampshire they'll live free or die state
because there's no need
for anybody to be forced into on their
private property
to have to call the government and say i
would like a little campfire out back so
i can have my grandkids over and we can
toast marshmallows and a hot dog
there's just no need for it
because i'm not going to burn my house
down i'm not burning my neighbor's house
down and my neighbors haven't burnt mine
down it just isn't going to happen
again the big fires
we aren't even talking about those
because that is not in the bill
if you look down in the bill
it says camp or cooking fires may be uh
built without permission this is on uh
uh
some public campgrounds
in picnic grounds areas so they're
already doing it without a permit in
some areas
i just want to extend that to your
private property in your backyard
so i hope you will pass this and
that's it thank you
any questions from members of the
committee
representative gould for a question
followed by representatives thank you mr
chairman and uh thank you representative
um
does this include those metal dishes
that you put a fire in that you need a
permit for
from what i understand and thank you for
the question
from what i understand if if you go to
the hardware store or anywheres and or
online you order these metal buckets you
know to put a campfire in
technically you are supposed to get a
permit for those
nobody i know does
and uh you know so that's why i'm saying
is i just want to clean the language up
that it's not
necessary and again you know this was uh
really during the first hearing they did
talk of it in the second here and uh you
know the second try of this this is my
third
that 70 to 75 percent of the people
don't realize they're supposed to get it
you know a permit thank you thank you
representative smith for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
i understand the uh wanting to have a
barbecue or campfire in your backyard in
one of the metal dishes
but
um can you show me where in the bill it
says it is limited to backyards because
the way i read it
i could get permission from a landowner
and they're like oh yeah sure do
whatever you want and i'm hiking back in
the woods with my grandchild and
building a campfire and then leave it
and then the fire goes down into the
duff and can cause a larger fire after
i'm gone so i don't i don't see anywhere
here where it limits it to that
what the instance you're talking about
could you explain that to me thank you
for the test uh your question absolutely
i can
you know can you do what you just
explained absolutely you could
but the majority of campfires are in
backyards there are the occasional one
up you know that people go in the woods
and and start their campfire
and let me look here okay it says right
here you know and i don't have the bill
you know i just copied this off the
internet so i don't have the actual
lines
but it's toward the end it says whoever
shall kindle or cause to be kindled any
such fire or use
an abandoned fire or in near wood lands
as you're talking shall totally
extinguish the uh
the same before leaving so it's in law
that you have to put that fire out and
it says that if you don't it says
failure to do so you're going to be held
personally liable
so that's already statute and that will
not be repealed the only thing that's
going to be repealed is written
permission from the the government
you know so i don't have to call the
fire department in bed chances are if
you go to the local you know force that
you want to go to or wherever you say
the scenario is
you know to your friend that has a lot
of land
chances are you're not going to call the
fire department you're going to go with
your child go out back and and build
that fire
i can't imagine you you know anybody
doing that scenario and then calling the
fire department and say okay i'm way up
in the woods here and i put my stones
around and i have a campfire that i want
to start but you need to come up and
give me permission first that's not
going to happen
it's just not
thank you
follow-up
are you are you aware that um the
permits can be applied for beforehand
and online also
yes i am thank you
any other questions
representative post
thank you mr chair and thank you john um
thank you representative
um
my question is the funds that are used
do you know how the funds are used that
they collect for these permits
i believe the permit's free
but it's still that you have to ask for
permission and then like in goffstown
um
you know
hopefully the goffstown's not watching
but i don't want the permit
and um
so they
they would have to come on my property
and and i wish not to have that
you know because i'm not gonna harm my
neighbors
you know so you know i just you know
it's just one way to to clean up the
language and to not have to ask the
government for something that is
rightfully yours
any other members of the committee for
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
and i do apologize but uh we're doing
exact sessions so if you don't mind i'll
leave oh no
i apologize for going so long and
keeping you here all right thank you
[Music]
steven sherman
dncr
department of
forest and lands
champ person renzullo and members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify on house bill
relative to repealing the permit for
fires at campgrounds
i do have written testimony which uh
hopefully you have
passed around
my name is steven sherman i'm the chief
of new hampshire of the new hampshire
forest protection bureau which is part
of the division of forests and lands
the department of natural and cultural
resources division of forest and lands
currently has no position on this bill
but we would like to make the following
comments
the division of forest and lands is
responsible for providing wildland fire
detection prevention and suppression on
all lands in the state
except for within the boundaries of the
white mountain national forest
this accounts for over 4.1 million acres
under our jurisdiction for wildland fire
protection
the division
as written house bill 1555
may not just repeal the fire permit
requirements for campgrounds as you just
heard it may repeal the permit
requirements for all category 1 and 2
fires
in the state
this comprises approximately 72 percent
of the permits issued each year
as defined in rule res 5601
category one and two fires a small
controlled fires such as camp or cooking
fires contained within a ring of fire
resistive material
and can be obtained
with a permit issued on a seasonal basis
uh the difference between category one
and two fires although they're both
campfires a category 1 fire is up to 24
inches in diameter and a category 2 fire
can be up to 48 inches in diameter
the language in house bill 1555 repeals
the permit requirement for camping
cooking fires without specifying whether
this is for all camper cooking fires or
just those within campgrounds
fire permits have been required in new
hampshire since 1911. and were put in
place to reduce fire occurrence during
periods of high fire danger
and to reduce carelessness with fire by
educating the public
the current fire permit system offers
both a paper permit
and an online permit option for
obtaining the fire permit and it can be
obtained both online as well as from
your local fire department and from the
local forest fire warden at no cost and
again on a seasonal yearly basis
the issuance of the fire permits gives
the fire officials the opportunity to
educate the public
about safe burning and reduces fires
during periods of high fire danger on
the local level
the fire permit system also allows for
fire officials to know where fires are
occurring thus preventing them from
responding with all of their apparatus
every time a smoke is reported
the issue
campgrounds in new hampshire are
currently required to obtain one
seasonal fire permit for the entire
campground for the year
the fire location is required to meet
the following specifications in
campgrounds
it has to be on an area cleaned
to mineral soil
at least eight feet across
it has to have at least six inches of
sand or gravel under the fire for any
fire that's built on the ground
uh limbs uh and burnable material have
to be cleared 10 feet above where the
fire is going to be located and the fire
has to be in a fire resistive ring that
can't be moved from that safe area
the division of forest lands understands
how important camp fires are to
campgrounds it's part of their business
model we understand that
and for that reason and because of the
extra precautions that i just mentioned
the division allows campgrounds to
continue burning during periods of high
fire danger
even when there are prohibitions put on
the general public
we believe that repealing the fire
permit requirement will increase fire
occurrence in new hampshire
uh it will increase the burden on local
fire departments municipal expenses and
increase the risk to both property and
lives during wildfires
thank you for the opportunity to testify
if i can provide any additional
information please let me know thank you
representative gould for a question okay
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
for taking my question um let me see
so a
a private homeowner can get a permit for
the whole year
correct and that is free
it's a free permit
issued
category one and two permits these
campfires it's a seasonal permit which
is good from the date the permits
obtained through december 31st okay
thank you thank you
representative huff for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question thank you for coming
out um you mentioned that there were
rules um
in place
such as cleaning out the you know the
area making sure my question is are
those rules only in place
when in conjunction with a fire permit
or would they be there regardless if
there was a fire permit or not
currently the
state statute which governs campgrounds
does specify
that it's there for campgrounds
part of that
rule part of that rsa also states that
campgrounds have to get a permit
so within our rules the forest fire
rules uh those specifications are
written into rules for the
campgrounds
so they go hand in hand hand in hand
okay follow up for a follow-up so would
there be a conflict
do you think there would be a conflict
or would that rule have to be addressed
also if
for example if this were to take place
i believe we would have to address the
rules and
update the rules thank you
representative gould for a second time
okay thank you mr chairman and thank you
again um
let me see uh
does the inspector come to my property
to check where i'm going to have the
fire
not in all cases
many times especially online
if somebody obtains the fire permit they
just check off the affidavit
saying that they understand the rules
and the laws
the local forest fire warden does have
the authority to enter onto the property
to check the burn location
but that isn't always the case even when
a paper permit is issued at the fire
department or by the local warden they
don't always conduct a site inspection
sometimes tuftonboro for example i know
does a site inspection the first time
they issue that seasonal permit and then
every year after as long as nothing's
changed with the site they just issue
the permit
represent representative gottlieb
for a question thank you um do you have
any uh statistics on the number of fires
that occur
either in the cities towns or in the
state
from small
or
from campfires
yes i do have um some statistics we do
not receive all um fire reports but the
ones we do receive
campfires
account for
approximately 35 to 40 percent of the
wildfires in new hampshire
in 2020 you may recall we had a drought
situation
and
that's when we started seeing a lot of
remote campfires
which turned into wildfires that took a
lot of time
to suppress
thank you
anyone else
uh i i do have a question a question or
two um
trying to
get my he uh my brain around what
constitutes a campfire and what is legal
and what requires a permit and what
doesn't does a grill require a permit
does a
outdoor cooking facility require a
permit
uh there are these
circular
circles of uh
uh that you that you buy at home depot
that have uh
the uh
bricks that you line up in a circle and
you have a a bowl like uh
device that you put wood in does that
require a permit there are these
ge anything powered with gas outside
does that require a permit
i'm
i'm not certain what
uh what requires a permit and what
doesn't
thank you for the question um charcoal
and gas grills those things they they do
not require a fire permit uh the fire
permit is for
um
the burning of of wood uh in a device
which does not have a chimney um which
is not enclosed
so those
circular brick with the metal insert
they're open flames so they would
require a permit
also no permit is required if there is
snow on the ground the fire permit is
tied directly to
wildfires and protecting the woodlands
from wildfires
thank you
any questions more questions from
members of the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time
calls j lord
from
yeah well n h f f f w a slash h f f d so
there's a lot of f's in there i know
i must stand for fire good morning and
thank you for your for your time um i'm
jay lord i'm the fire chief in hampton
falls new hampshire and i'm also the
president of the new hampshire forest
fire
federation of forest fire wardens
associations that's what all the f's are
um
to give you a quick rundown every town
has a fire chief and or a forest warden
the wardens then have a every county has
a forest warden group and then the state
all get together and that's what i'm the
president of i'm here today to quickly
talk about opposing this bill
in the fact that this bill is more of a
an ounce of prevention
is better than a pound of cure
by having the um ability to
write a permit
from the municipal side of it is
gives us that ability to educate the
public you yourself are unsure about
what requires a permit whether it's gas
or wood or
if it's a dish or if it's a chiminea or
whatever
and
by us being able to write those permits
to go to visit people to answer those
questions it really helps
by
defining to them
you're not supposed to put this on your
deck because it will start your
your siding on fire and burn your house
down or put it 25 feet away from your
house so that you have a defensible
space against anything else
against your house against your shed
against your fence
by having the uh by keeping the fire
permit in the campgrounds
it also allows us to go visit those
campgrounds once a year to make sure
that the the pits themselves
are they have the proper clearance that
they're well maintained
new hampshire's economy a good portion
of the economy is based on recreation
and the tourism
and by
making sure that safe from
any kind of fire problem
allows folks to want to come to new
hampshire to to recreate
the the
the the statement about the little
campfire doesn't isn't any a big deal
i can personally say i've been on the
i've been to the western fires i've been
to every year i go to the 400 000 acre
the 500 000 acre i've been to the
million acre fire
that was caused by a by a campfire every
fire that's giant starts small it starts
at a spark smokey bear taught us that a
million years ago
and
it's something that just doesn't
resonate with a lot of people
there is a cost to this to the local
fire department
depending on how your local fire
department pays their folks or or
compensates their folks
if the tone goes some everybody has a
cell phone now
it used to be if you saw a fire or smoke
you went someplace you went to the fire
department now it's
i was driving by and smelled smoke at
such and such a place
if i have gone there already
to inspect their ugly oh i know they
have a campfire there the seasonal
permit not a big deal but i'll go check
it out anyways if i don't know that
i'm rolling out three pieces of
apparatus
before i even roll out those three
pieces of apparatus
i have to get my volunteer departments
to the station
i then have to roll out that piece of
apparatus i now have to send these down
and
when's the last time a fire truck came
up behind you
did you properly pull over to the right
of the road and stop and let them go by
or did you stop in the middle of the
road
or did you turn you know just do
something absolutely insane
these are the things that happen when
when people see fire trucks
the less time i have to have a fire
truck on the road the less time i have
to worry about any kind of damage to
that piece of apparatus therefore
another cost to the town
so
it's it's not a it's not
a
no cost to the town issue there is a
cost to the town issue but the cost is
so minute if you ask for a free permit
we come in we do a little education
we move on we answer your questions
about everything else because it might
be the one time of year
that you actually get to talk to
somebody from the fire department and
ask them that question has been burning
for six months
so
is this is this bill free no is this
built should this
be repealed
this this should die this is not
something that should be passed
and uh
can i answer any questions for you
any questions by members of the
committee representative creighton
thank you mr chairman chief thank you
for your testimony i i'm
having a little problem connecting
though
if if we repeal this and you don't have
to get a permit okay does that mean then
you cannot inspect a campground
because that's what you just said i'm
gonna
so it's it's
if if you take this away
i
i don't need to inspect that campground
but you can but i can but it but it it
it's almost that that
i don't want to say that the government
the the concern of the of the author of
this bill is that the government is
going to come and tell me what to do
it really is more of of an education
and making sure that we're on the same
page
that yes i can come and inspect you
because i have other laws and rules that
allow me to do that as the fire chief
but
as the campground owner or the home
owner am i going to do that no not
necessarily
but i go back to my statement about
everybody has a cell phone when they
drive by and say i smelled smoke at the
corner of of
elm and main street
well where are you now i'm
five miles away
was it a campfire or was it a bonfire
well i don't know
so now as a local fire department i'm
now rolling out apparatus and personnel
to something that really
could have been taken care of by a quick
hey you got a campsite there
for a follow-up
um
okay and
our fire chief in the interim is a great
guy
i'm one of that 30 percent that has had
a permit for the last seven years
uh he's never been to my house and
and i talked to him on a regular basis i
don't think he goes to anyone's house
so i i
i'm just a little skeptical on that but
thank you for your input appreciate it
thank you
any more questions from the
members from the members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time
i having no more
i have no no more pink cards
so i will uh
declare the
hearing on house bill
adjourn
and i will open the
hearing on
house bill
14 18.
chair recognizes representative posts
is uh your
are you on i hit the wrong button sorry
um
again thank you for um hearing me today
i'm here to
introduce
house bill 1418
this is relative to
permit notification for certain home
owner share
shoreline projects
this was brought to me as a constituent
request
and this was
brought up because people who live on
lakes and
rivers and shorelines and even tidal
waters
when they have damage to their property
they've found it very onerous to
be able to go through the permitting
process
to be able to
um
fix the their erosion problems um from
uh
boats when
there's ex excessive um speeding and the
waves come in and
um
and and other issues that happen uh
because of you know natural
conditions winds and things like that
that damage their shoreline
um so
and many people told
me that they had difficulties filling
out the forms and they had to go to
lawyers and it was very expensive there
were was
excessive time
in in getting this done
and
because of folks not being able to
either afford to get a lawyer to do this
or have been denied or have not heard
back
from the
des
on permitting
they have often done things um what they
call
midnight gardening and
and then
what will happen is a neighbor or
someone sees that something's changed
and they'll report it and these folks
can get fined
so in order for people to do things
legally appropriately
we were putting this bill in place so
that it would simplify the process make
it easier you wouldn't need to go to a
lawyer to to be able to fill out these
forms
and so in this process for this bill um
i worked uh
with the des
and they have assured me
that
because these are
the rules they they get to put forth
that
they will be going back to a simplified
version
and it will be more consumer-friendly
and
there's time limitations and prior to
this they had not provided actual
permits
now they will be
um
providing the homeowners a a an actual
physical permit and if it is denied
there is an opportunity for
them to come in either prior to making
their their changes or
their projects they can go in
and and ask for help from the des and if
it's after and denied there is a time
period where they can go in and work
with them again to to see what can be
done and they will get a denial
um so at this point i feel that we don't
need to have this bill
and um so i'm in support of um
either itling it or laying it on a table
what they have assured me is that
these changes will be made
in around six to eight months which i
think would be
more prudent if we put this bill forth i
think it would take much longer it would
also one of the things they um
they spoke to me about is by opening
this up it could create
other statutes to be affected and it
might take
longer for this to get approved so
i would
ask for your support in either
itling or laying it on the table in case
we need something in the future
first of all
for uh there is no such thing as laying
it on a table in in committee
thank you could probably
we can discuss right now we're in the
middle of
it is in a hearing
hearing
uh we
uh
but also we're
have people here to testify i think we
should
allow them to
to speak as well
and then
after
there's also a few questions that might
be asked but
i'll say that
we can discuss what we what might be
done well
we'll do it in in open session
[Music]
but representative cohen you had a
question representative post thank you
for taking my question
um
i just have a quick question about you i
respect your recommendation
uh on what you want to do with this bill
because there are other reps on this
bill that can't testify because they
can't answer questions because they're
sitting out here i'm just curious from
your personal experience do you think
that these other reps on co-sponsor the
bill will go along with your
recommendation as well
thank you for the question um
i did send out an email but it was quite
late i just met with the des yesterday
um because i was aware that
there might be an amendment needed to do
this and in our discussion
we talked about this bill and realized
or or i felt comfortable with
letting the des handle it within their
rules to simplify it
so i have not heard from any of the
other sponsors on there but
i'd be happy to hear from them and
if they're in support of continuing it i
would
agree with that as well but
i do feel that we have an opportunity to
work with them and
get this done
more quickly
thank you
uh
there's
two two of your uh
co-sponsors are
sitting on this committee normally they
cannot speak you just have to
but i would
[Music]
i would allow them to
say whether or not they agree with what
you say and
then
if if it's agreement fine if it's not
then you'll have to testify
reasonable
representative harb i agree with the
comments and the new statement from
representative post thank you
and i do the same
you're your representative
yes
that any other questions from members of
the committee
seeing none
thank you and
thank you very much uh i do have a card
from darlene forest from new hampshire
department of environmental services
good morning my name is darlene forrest
i'm the wetlands bureau administrator at
the new hampshire department of
environmental services i'd like to thank
you all for allowing us this opportunity
to speak thank you mr chairman
at this time in light of
representative post's
actions this morning
what we would like to do is simply thank
representative post harvey balea and har
for their willingness to continue to
work with us
and we look forward to working with you
and improving this process which we
acknowledge
and we're already in the process of
making these changes
so we thank you for
your your efforts in this and your
concerns on this and have no further
testimony at this time
so thank you for being here today and um
oh representative post you cannot answer
ask a question i'm sorry
thank you very thank you very much
see always glad to have other eyes
watching me
any any other any questions from
somebody who's allowed to speak please
ask a question
representative
thank you mr chairman could you explain
um what is being done or or what you
folks are
trying to do
in in lieu of of what this would be
having you uh or or asking you to do
okay so
the bill is currently written would
affect rulemaking authority under
shoreland unfortunately the processes
that we're discussing are not under the
shoreline protection act they're under
wetlands
we are already in early draft stages of
wetland rulemaking
to
take the
parts of this form which are
hardest to understand
in that they refer people to large
sections of rules and require the
reading of these sections in their
entirety instead of just picking out
selected items we are already in the
process of that wetland rule correction
we hope to
have an initial draft we hope to have
initiated that rule-making process and
be at the point of
having publicly viewable versions of
those new rules
this summer
so as you know the rulemaking process um
takes a little bit of time the drafts
are in process
we should have a draft for public
comment and viewing this summer so you
guys can see firsthand and part of that
will be required revised forms so you
will see hard copies of this excellent
thank you
any other questions
seeing none
thank you very much
before
i gavel this
closed
there's some things that we have we
might
i think you might be interested in
listening uh guys
the uh
what to do
we could
i know it was in my uh
my authority
to
call for uh to
enter executive session and dispose of
the bill if we wish
i will i don't like to do that
that's and
uh
against
i've done it one time
in
my
chair career
i would not do i won't do it unless i
have agreement from everyone here
that we
should be to be able to
uh bring this
bill to exec this bill
uh
just just this bill that's all uh just
this bill to be able to get it off the
off the table and then it's
it it's gone
uh
i would uh
for a discussion or representative huff
you had a question
um yeah i just wanted to um to say to
the committee that um if if you were to
choose to execute this bill i would
consider making a motion to retain the
bill
that would have been my recommendation
no not retention
yeah
right retain second year retain is only
the first year yeah interim study what
that would do we do have some interim
study bills
uh
left over we
are we do have several bills
one that comes at least one these these
septic system ones
so we do have to meet on that
uh later on in the year
so
every uh do i have agreement from the
from the committee to
enter into executive session
mr chair i hate to
be opposing your suggestion but
um i would feel more comfortable if it
was advertised and we just put it on the
exec list and not post it that it's
going to be on exec list whether you
have the authority or not i'd like to
just stay in consistent that we're going
to post that we're going to exact it i
don't think we're going to take a long
time to execute it so it won't take a
long time when you actually put out your
list of exact exacting so i'd like to
just wait and do it when we post
if you wish
yes mr chairperson i respect your
authority and ability to call an
executive session anytime you want so
i'm just suggesting that informally we
understood that there would be none
today again i know that you can do that
and that there are several of
my
peers that are not here today i mean i
intend to support
representative post's suggestion but i
think we'd rather give the opportunity
just to have more people here that
thought there might not be an executive
session again i respect that you can
call at any time and it's your
discretion
gonna open up house bill 1620
identifying part of the merrimack river
as
prote as a protected river
recognized uh
representative russell russ berry
thank you members of the committee um my
name is uh ross berry i'm representative
from the city of manchester on the south
side and the town
of litchfield
litchfield those you don't know is on
the other side of the town of merrimack
and was just as affected by water
quality issues
so water quality issues are a
it's an extensive concern for the people
that i represent the one thing that
binds my two communities together
outside of those who commute from
manchester from litchfield to manchester
is the merrimack river itself
so the state established
this program that allows for the
designation of status
of the river of rivers for protection
and there's varying different degrees of
protection that the state allows
a rural river a natural river
and a community river
and each of those designations has
different levels of protection mostly
surrounding
wastewater issues
fertilizer use and and um some things to
do with motorized vehicles
so what i am attempting to do is add in
the section of the merrimack river that
runs through the city um and hooks it
down to the state line the community
designate the community designation for
the river already exists starting in the
town of merrimack
the only section of the merrimack river
of
i don't want to say significance but
let's say significant population portion
that isn't covered by this program is
actually the section that runs through
manchester um manchester is known for
let's say our abuse of the river as a
whole i read a study once it said nearly
half of the pollution that comes into
the merrimack river comes from my city
due to our sewage issues
and we do have a consent decree that was
signed with the environmental protection
agency i believe i want to say a little
over a year ago
to resolve that issue and i did put in a
clause in the bill that would prohibit
this protection status from interfering
with that consent decree i figure if
it's good enough for the epa it's
probably good enough uh for the um
it is probably good enough for this act
which is
much more um
uh narrower um so a couple of statements
i'd like to read full disclosure this is
not an area of expertise of mind i mean
this is a constituent concern but it is
not i do not pretend to be as
knowledgeable about this as the people
behind me um or the committee members
themselves
but the res the river designation as a
community established increases public
awareness of the river and creates a
local community planning and management
efforts centered specifically on the
river and its resources this local
community
group basically already exists we're
just tacking it into the existing one
because once again the community river
designation already exists immediately
south of the manchester line
by law the only land use protection
measures that are added with the
community designation are those for
solid and hazardous waste facilities and
uh and first second and third order
streams
and those described in the shoreline
water protection act so this doesn't
affect any existing landfill or
wastewater facility
they can still expand they can still
operate but they cannot build a new one
within 250 feet of the shoreline
so for those of you who are not familiar
with manchester i don't know where you
would build
a wastewater facility or landfill within
250 feet of our shoreline but this would
be that would be the major prohibition
on the use of this river um river
designations can increase property can
respect can increase respect for
property rights and heightened
heightened recognition of the valuable
contribution which land owners already
make in river protection issues such as
trespassing liability and erosion effect
or infringe upon the rights of river of
river land owners
community rivers or segment flows
through developed or populated areas
uh
are readily accessible by this is the
this is the designation of the community
river excuse me
they are
they're segments that flow through
developed or populated areas manchester
um and are readily accessible by road or
railroad
manchester um these rivers may include
existing or potential empowerments or
diversions for hydropower flood control
or water supply as well as urban centers
manchester that could qualify for
shoreline water quality protection act
urban exemptions so basically the
community river designation is for
places like manchester for places like
merrimack it's or places like nashua
i don't know why they didn't include
this section of the river or
initially in this my only gut and i am
speculating here is that because of our
known sewage issues in manchester they
probably wouldn't have qualified so when
it rains really heavily in manchester
this is the consent decree with the epa
we do not handle the overflow
we shamefully dump that overflow into
the merrimack once again half of the
pollution from the merrimack comes from
manchester once again epa consent decree
we are fixing that um but now that that
issue is being resolved this will kind
of shore up so those things can't happen
again because it is not good to pollute
the rivers so with that i will and one
other thing
the community river designation program
has a
process an rsa by which they
they want you to follow
it's community input
those sort of deals
i understand that there's been some
issues with some people that with some
organizations that
are associated that are interested in
this who support the concept but don't
support the way about which we're doing
it
i'll tell you right now as legislators
existing law cannot tell you how you can
make future law only the new hampshire
state constitution can do that if
there's concerns about the public having
a hearing i'd like to welcome you to the
public hearing
about making this section of the
merrimack river a public designated
community river um so i i find those um
i find those
um
reasons for opposition to be
let's say uh we're talking about rivers
so shallow
but i have worked with des on this my
understanding is they are supportive of
the concept of making the river giving
this river its designation
and i'm happy to go through some of the
i have it here some of the protections
outside of the 250
foot abatement
for sorry i'm looking up all the headway
speed
so you can still drive your boat uh you
can't drive your boat super fast within
150 feet of the shoreline merrimack
river is about 600 feet wide not a
problem
you can still build new hydroelectric
facilities so if we decide to build more
hydro we can continue to do that you
have to have a fish ladder the only
existing height there's two existing
hydro facilities in manchester one of
them's really small only operates in the
spring and summer
and the big one the yamaskeg break guess
what it has a fish ladder you can go and
visit it it's called the the sea center
it's very nice you can look at it you
can see the little salmon
swimming up it's really nice
um you can still expand existing
landfills you just can't build a new one
within 250 feet which i don't know who
wants to build a a new landfill um
and you sorry not to the landfill
exceptions not 250 it's 100. so it's 100
feet uh of the shoreline or the 500 year
floodplain so the landfill can't flood
and flood back into the river every 500
years but it's a very very minimal
designation it's not going to change
things really much at all other than
make have this committee and this body
make the statement that hey let's not
pollute the merrimack this is this is a
community river let's put it with the
rest of the uh the towns to the south
that's all i got you
any questions
for the representative
you have a question representative
harvey bullion for our question
representative uh
can you tell me how this would impact uh
building permits
um
so des may be better suited to answer
that but my understanding is it won't um
when i spoke with ds initially they may
have to do
to just notify
the
existing community
group that oversees it but it's not they
don't get approval it's literally hey i
planned on doing this
but it mostly only pertains to
the building of new waste facilities and
i specifically asked des about
leech fields
going in because that's obviously a
concern specifically for bedford and
hooksett there are sec parts of those
communities that are not on community
water systems yet
and obviously didn't want to do it and
they assured me it was not a problem you
can you could they could still get their
leach fields in they can still make
their new developments
it is a designation that this river it's
a it's a designation of the river and
bringing it into
where it is the irony is it's the
designation exists to the north the
designation it just doesn't exist in
in manchester and to my friends uh south
of us i'm sorry about what we've been
doing to the river
question by anyone
else seeing no one
thank you very much off to election law
thank you
okay
uh
mr sanborn from the des
assistant
commissioner
good morning thank you mr chairman
for the record mark sanborn
assistant commissioner bes
um
some of my colleagues from the es are
going to speak to the more technical
aspects of the bill
i just wanted to
approach some of a couple of larger
issues number one apologize to the
committee we already
apologized to the sponsor for
the miscommunication in our office about
sending two letters of testimony
um
that letter was sent before final review
and it won't happen again and we
apologize so i thought it was important
to clear up where we are on this issue
number one we do support the underlying
goal
of the issue
of the bill that
representative barry brought forward
number two
there was some
there is a process in terms of involving
the public we've already offered
representative barry will work with him
on getting letters from the three
communities
that can be added to the record for you
all to
consider as part of it i'm showing their
support which
would make us a lot more comfortable in
terms of that public outreach aspect
um and we're also very grateful to
um
representative barry he didn't mention
his testimony i hate this before but i
think if you ask them he said he was
very open to the amendment we suggested
in the letter
that we sent all of you that will clean
up the underlying statute itself and
we think we'll really improve the
statute
so just wanted to kind of uh again given
the multiple letters
kind of clarify
um
thank you mr chair and thank you for
being here today um i just had a
question
did did those documents come out already
or is there one out for us in our box
and then
thank you
representative smith for a question
thank you mr chair and uh thank you mr
sanborn for taking my question sorry my
mic is kind of putting you out of field
of vision there we go i got it
um
yeah
us too um the question i have is that
you know we do have a process in place
for the rivers program and how rivers
are designated and we have had other
rivers
come before us for the final seal of
approval here
and it seems like that process has not
happened
and are you saying that the letter from
des
about these of different communities
will serve that purpose or
so it won't come from us we're gonna
we're gonna reach out to the mansion
we're gonna work with representatives
okay
follow-up
um
the bill as i read it says it goes from
the massachusetts state line
up to manchester hooksett is what is
written in it
so
that's seems like more than just two or
three communities oh but part of it is
already got it
thank you
anyone else for a question
could you shut your mic off
anyone else for uh questions
uh actually maybe i'll i'll ask one uh
i maybe someone already knows i'll have
to try to find out
if it goes to the massachusetts line it
goes right past
hudson and litchfield
[Music]
one of which is my town is that already
okay fine all right uh anyway
representative creighton
yes mr chair thank you very much mr
sanborn thank you and it's a follow-up
to representative smith's question just
to make sure i'm understanding with
these three letters
does that meet the rsa requirement
procedurally
so
is just um to show deference to our
friends in the legislative
uh branch know under your authority so
our goal was to try and um
use the combination of during public
hearings we're having one right now
the discussion will be held in public
and outreach the community was just our
goal of making the best with the
situation
um but
no that that is not how the rsa process
would have been followed
and for a follow-up sir
so what is not being done then um
a lot more interaction with the
communities
and
opportunities
okay thank you very much
um this is a comment i believe the
speaker does not have his microphone on
because people are texting me saying
they can't hear at home
very good you were right the whole time
luckily i'm pretty loud so you probably
heard most of it
seeing no other questions thank you very
much thank you mr chair and committee
members appreciate it
now
mr dears
press the button i can do that you're
right i'm qualified
thank you uh mr chair members of the
committee it's a pleasure to be in front
of you here today my name is ted diers
and i am the administrator of the
watershed management bureau
i'm sorry watershed management bureau at
the department of environmental services
and um i am going to speak to the second
part of our letter which was regarding
the original legislation that caused the
creation of the merrimack designation
back in 1990
citation occurred and there was some
language
put into the bill at that time that
restricted
uh well you could either look at it
restricted or allocated a certain
portion of flow to the pentachuck
waterworks
so this is an interesting artifact
of the ancient now becoming ancient
history now of of the river's
designation
that um looked at what was going to
happen under in-stream flow protection
at that time and i started looking at
in-stream flow rules in new hampshire in
when i was working for a non-profit and
so it's been a really long
and interesting journey to get to the
point we are today
but back then the conversation was
really about some of the rudimentary
ways we were thinking about in-stream
flow
things that could have had draconian
limits placed on to certain activities
um and so
over the years as you all have been
aware because many of you have followed
this journey over the years have now a
tried and true method
that is river specific and highly
scientific way of looking at in-stream
flow and what we have found is that it
is extraordinarily fair to the water
users and make sure that people get the
water they need at the same time
that we protect the biota within our
rivers so the system is really working
so so what you see here is a relic
of that old conversation
given and i know you are well well aware
of this given where many of you are from
the issues with pfas and other issues
with contaminated drinking water it does
not seem prudent to be limiting specific
intakes for specific
to specific flows any longer because we
have a really good methodology to make
sure that that we don't impact the river
with water use
and we have a need now for flexibility
to make sure that we can we can address
the very significant
water quality and drinking water issues
which you all have heard much about uh
in front of your committee
so uh we have recommended a uh
an amendment to this bill uh it's been
discussed uh with a sponsor
and the idea here is basically to take
out that language and this would be very
much what all of the other designated
rivers have they don't have specific
either limits or allocations to specific
water users this would put them sort of
at par with everything else we've also
discussed this with pennichuck water
works
clearly they were named in this and they
too and i'm not sure if you've gotten a
letter from penichak yet or not but we
have had conversations with them they
too favor
the removal of this language from that
designation
i'm going to stop there and see if
anyone has any questions
about all of that
any questions by a member of the
committee on that issue
representative smith thank you very much
and thank you mr dears for taking my
question and welcome back to the
committee
um so you were commenting pretty much
just on the part that talks which is
related to the in-stream flow
program
um on the part of the part two of the
of the letter yes ma'am okay
and you're not
speaking you you're not the person are
you the person to ask about what is
required what are all the rules for
designating a river that we presently
have in statute so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to bring tracy sales up who
is our rivers and management uh rivers
and lakes management
rivers and lakes programs manager
did i get it all right
administrator goodness gracious so tracy
if you could come on up here
and talk a little bit about what some of
those other
aspects of nominations
would include
um and
i guess just try to summarize
for the record my name is tracy sills i
am the rivers and lakes programs
administrator at the new hampshire
department of environmental services
under normal circumstances when a river
is nominated into the rivers management
and protection program
this comes from a group of local
citizens interested in protecting their
river they are interested in working
together
between the towns that share the
resource of the river and also working
together more closely with the state
to better protect their river
so this is a grassroots effort typically
and what would normally happen is that
group would start by putting together
a resource assessment what is what is
special about the river and why should
it be uh protected what are the problems
with the river whether that's water
quality or development or anything else
that you know what threats are are out
there
on this river so they put together a
you know 50-page plus document
which really looks at and examines
what's going on on the river
based on that they then say we really
want to protect this river they bring
that to the various towns within the
length of the river that they're going
to do
they also contact every single riparian
landowner along that stretch of river
and say hey here's what we're looking at
doing they hold information meetings
they hold public hearings
to make sure that everybody has been
heard
once that is done
we contact you we have public hearings
with
the
this committee as well as the the senate
energy and natural resources committee
um that document and then goes to the
commissioner of des to
for his approval then we write a bill
then we come to you guys and say
this is what we'd like to do here are
all the people that support it here's
why we want to do it and here's the
background research that indicates why
that should be done in addition this is
also vetted by the rivers management
advisory committee and the chair of that
committee is here today
so the statewide rivers management
advisory committee will also look at
this
to determine whether or not this
nomination into the program is
appropriate
under the rules of the program
so they will also look at it
that's a very different
process do you feel that that is an
effective process
i do and i think it worked really well
in the last designation that we had
which was for the warner river and the
warner river
actually was a three-year nomination
process and it took that long because
there were people who were not
comfortable with a couple of the
provisions that would have
been made under the original original
proposal for the designation there were
some
dam owners in particular who were
concerned and so the nominating
committee worked with those dam owners
changed some of the
classifications that representative
barry had been talking about
and made it so that everybody was could
accept and was happy with that
designation
thank you
one more follow-up for a follow-up
um all of a sudden i went blank um
never mind thank you
representative representative harp for a
question thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question this is a
historical question for me
and you may not have the answer but it
was mentioned that we as a committee in
the legislature have a power to overrule
the process that was mentioned
do you know if any other section of the
merrimack river has bypassed
that public hearing session like are we
setting a precedent or is this the first
portion of the merrimack river where
we're bypassing all this public
uh information and all that input that
you just gave us
this is the first time that i know of
that this process has been bypassed all
of the other uh 19 rivers and river
segments that have been designated in
the past have followed the process in
statute and rule
thank you
this isn't this is an attempt to bypass
right this
hasn't been bypassed yet
uh
who
representative post for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your information you gave us today um i
just wonder if bypassing that system is
going to create the existing system in
bringing this forward
if that's going to create a problem
so
just a second um so
i think it's an interesting question
it hasn't happened before
so you know theoretically
we don't we don't really know
um because this hasn't gone this way
before
i think as tracy described the process
has worked really well in the past and
it's also worked the opposite way
for those of you who are on the
committee to remember the uh hem branch
remember the ham branch we actually had
a subcommittee led by representative
rice which i affectionately called the
ham and rice committee
um
and so
in that case uh what the legislature
heard at the end of that was that there
was not support
uh amongst certain parties for the
designation and so ultimately and i
think this is where representative barry
was correct it's you all
are the ones who make the final decision
about how this goes down
so
the process does seem to work
whether it becomes on the affirmative or
on the negative the the process is good
in that it helps to vet
all of the concerns so that when you all
um have to make a decision you're doing
that from an informed perspective so i
think that that's really the the only
concern that we had about that part of
the bill was really about making sure
that you all
are sitting there with the information
that you need to make the decision about
how this moves forward so i think you
know that's the i think the framework
that we come at this with did you have
something else
so again one of the
outcomes of designating a river is the
formation of a local advisory committee
this particular bill
would append
the manchester uh bedford and
hooksett thank you
sections two the existing lower
merrimack river designation and i was
actually having a chat yesterday with
the existing a couple of the existing
members of the um
the lower
segment of the river and a they were
very surprised about this um and i had
had hoped that representative barry
would reach out to them
but they were not aware of it and they
they actually while they support
designating the middle section of the
merrimack
um
they are they feel like it should be its
own committee
rather than um
being appended to theirs they feel like
they have enough work to do
um
so
again it's it's part about getting local
support but if
um
if this were to go through
we don't have a base of
interested
community members who are willing to
work with
the other community members to help
protect that river because it's really
about the people
in those communities
thank you mr chairman um
this process how long does it take
normally two years approximately and for
a follow-up sir
in your work with uh on this bill and
and working with the amendment and
everything
uh do you have a sensing of of what the
rush is
to bypass this
i am
again i i think the representative
barry's um introduction spoke to his
rationale
for wanting to add this in um i think
the certainly the rationale is
um
is is the same rationale of why we
protect rivers
that is that we protect rivers for the
for the very
for the attributes that they bring the
through the love of the river that the
people have around it um and he spoke to
that so so i don't
don't believe that there's any nefarious
purpose oh no i'm not that's not my name
i'm just curious
yeah if there's a process why you
wouldn't follow that so so
that it would be a question but i think
for the for the representative okay all
right i can't speak for him thank you
representative smith for a second time
and then rep representative post for a
second time thank you i remembered my
question
um the first time that the process went
through it was for the whole river and
manchester declined to participate is
that my understanding is that correct
well i have to say 1990 was before my
time
but my understanding is the proposal
initially um
and
michelle tremblay may have a little bit
more information was for the whole the
entire river at the time um
as ted was describing there was concern
about the in-stream flow program and the
restrictions that that might place on
manchester so they declined
um to participate at that time so we
split the
merrimack into an upper and lower
segment okay thank you
representative post
for a follow-up question thank you mr
chair so at this point would you
make a recommendation at all that that
the public it should go through the
public system or are you comfortable
where you're at well i think that as as
assistant commissioner sanborn spoke to
this
we think that you all need to hear from
the communities
that this river travels through
unless they're here today or have
provided you testimony already
we are not aware that this conversation
has happened within the communities
and that may have happened but we are
not aware of that and we aren't aware of
that so we can't bring it to your
attention and make you aware of that
and so i think this was the concern that
we have and i think that at least a next
step
and wherever you decide to go after that
but certainly the next step would be for
you all to hear from the communities
that are affected by this particular
piece of legislation to understand where
they sit on it
um because we just don't know that and i
think that as representative as
assistant commissioner sanborn indicated
we're certainly helpful certainly help
happy to help out sometimes we're
helpful sometimes we're not but
we are certainly happy to help to
identify the the contacts within those
communities and make sure that they're
aware
of this piece of legislation and
afford them the opportunity to be able
to at least to help you all be informed
about your um decision that would come
up on this particular bill so that that
was really our perspective is that once
you hear from them i think you all will
have an opportunity to decide
what is your what is the next course of
action that you'd like to take do you
think that they should do more do you
think that that shows substantial um
agreement
that i think that's the conversation
between you all and the sponsor and
leadership here
uh
i've got your name ted but i don't have
your name uh
could you fill out a pink card maybe
that'll do it i will do that i
appreciate it
and send it up
anyone else
okay
that being uh will
thank you very much and uh
thank you very much
i have two cards for michelle trembley
are you are you
uh are you a split personality
okay i will start with the new hampshire
rivers council thank you representative
egan
um i have been around since the
1980s when the program was envisioned
the new hampshire rivers council was
once the new hampshire rivers campaign
it was a group of citizens and
communities that got together and
decided that river protection was
necessary and so it passed that bill and
for those of you who have been around as
long as i have you might remember a very
conservative person crowe dickinson who
was supportive of this bill but one of
the things that he wanted to make sure
was that everyone would be involved in a
designation and so
the uh the process included many steps
to make sure that all along the way
people were involved and i'll speak to
chair of the river's management advisory
committee in a moment but
the study has to go before the rivers
management advisory committee and if
there is not sufficient support
documented in writing
a it has to be from all of the
municipalities but it has to be from
others as well
then it never gets so far as to be
recommended and that's usually where it
dies unless there's
you know someone who's trying to go
around it so i just wanted to mention a
couple of points there
and that is that
that is the reason for the process the
rivers council which was the campaign is
very concerned about the precedent that
this might set and also sort of the
black eye on the program and then
should the bill pass and there are
people who get very upset about it and
want to withdraw from the program then
the statute will have to be reopened
and that brings with it more work for
you and a host of other issues that i
think none of us want to see
no river segment in the entire state has
ever bypassed the process
and for instance the lamprey river
decided it wanted to have a broader
reach it went through everything all
over again the study the community
involvement the reaching out to
legislators asking them if they wanted
to serve locally this all was
completely and utterly the same as they
did before so they didn't even try to do
anything sort of on the quick even
though they already had a designation in
place
so we are incredibly supportive of the
idea of
having the middle merrimack in the
program as long as it does what all the
other segments did
and to fill in a little bit of that
history
from the hookset line down to the
manchester bedford line it was the
manchester water works it was the city
of manchester it was then the public
service company
that didn't want to see
this designation for their own reasons
and so that's why it was not included
and
none of those interests i believe are
aware of it although we do have the new
hampshire water works association here
so they're aware of it now
and
you know i'm
surprised that the city of manchester
the town of bedford for instance are not
here and i think that it's not just
about the city or town leaders it's
about everyone including the businesses
along the way
so i would urge that
we send a message to representative
barry that we're opposing the bill and
it's an expedient to legislate but that
we'd like to begin working with him the
way we have in the satisfying way that
we have with the other committees so
i'll stop being the new hampshire risk
counsel and i can change to a different
personality if you don't have any
questions
any questions by
any members of the committee
all right very quickly the rivers uh
management advisory committee letter is
coming around with a fact sheet from the
department's website so you can get a
sense of how the program works
and very briefly what we're looking to
talk about there is that
it's very important for all of us to be
involved in this process the
rmac as it is known conducts a public
hearing in the communities it conducts a
tour that everyone comes on that's
interested and that way first hand we
have an idea of why the river is special
we get to hear from citizens
and then if we don't see the support and
have it documented in writing then we
don't recommend it so i don't want to be
repetitious but you do have that letter
in that fact sheet
and i'm happy to answer any questions
and i wanted to also give you the
connecticut river conservancy's letter
in opposition they're highly concerned
about the precedent even though they're
on what they call new hampshire's west
coast they're really concerned about the
precedent
and as a chair of a local advisory
committee when
the lower merrimack decided that they
didn't want to see this happen and be
annexed as the term was used
they suggested that the upper merrimack
be the one to be annexed and we also
have plenty of work to do as volunteers
and i think that it's important for
those communities to form their own
group
the nomination committee often becomes
the local advisory committee and
the communities often just
ultimately decide the city of manchester
would decide the town of bedford would
decide who they want to work on their
committees
so sorry about the
the trifecta of personalities but i
thought the different perspectives might
be helpful to you
and also that i'm the oldest person in
the room at least
as a volunteer working on this program
still let you know both cards
are in the record
okay thank you
is uh any uh
any more any questions
the oldest person in the room doesn't
get any questions are you taking pity on
me oh
you're certainly not the oldest person
in the room not
oh no
i i know i have i have shoes older than
you
i mean believe me
well we'll talk after the hearing
um thank you all very much for your time
i really appreciate it and i hope that
we can um
have this bill be inexpedient to
legislate but also that we send a strong
message to representative barry that
river conservation is wonderful we are
grateful and look forward to working
with him
on the process i think he'll find it
rewarding and the results certainly
stick
thank you very much
thank
you uh and boyd smith
from the new hampshire water works
association
yes sir thank you chair and uh i'm
appreciative that you uh recognize the
acronym there it's
a good sign um i do have copies of uh
written testimony i sent it in advance
should i send that around one pager for
this bill
i hate to ask you because all right
if you do how many do you have 20 20 or
21 should have enough yeah if
you have a hard copy yes
um a lot of what i was going to say has
been touched on again for the record my
name is boyd smith i'm the president and
ceo of the new hampshire water works
association
and uh we represent the drinking water
sector in the state of new hampshire
that serves roughly 54 of our people
with
safe clean and affordable drinking water
one of the biggest sources of drinking
water for the biggest systems is the
merrimack river
surface water is is you know what feeds
manchester and benechuck of course and
and other systems
so uh that's really one of the drivers
for being here today
the
the merrimack as we know is being used
and as some of you may know is uh the
city of manchester is putting in a new
treatment plant to expand their capacity
another seven million gallons a day
i think we can all expect that our
surface water will continue to be
used into the future our needs are just
likely going to grow so taking care of
our resources is our source waters is a
top priority for the sector as i'm sure
you all understand
um so our group is uh i like to just
remind folks that they're um
they're they're public servants and they
think of themselves and i'm new to this
group but i've heard numerous people say
uh we're health providers we're in it
for public health uh our product people
drink our product and i'm just saying
this because i want to uh reinforce the
nature of the somewhat hidden social
service that we all depend on uh there's
a good bunch of people
they'll follow they want to follow
science and regulations and well thought
out policy because
they want to implement it well and of
course policy decisions have
implications cost implica cost
implications and others
so the bottom line we did oppose the
bill and there may be some amendments
around that we haven't seen yet that may
change this
but
the reason we oppose it is because we
believe we should use the existing
process that's been discussed most
thoroughly uh by by ms tremblay
under the existing rsa
to
to get the buy-in and the group
understanding to make a decisions about
future water use these these rivers are
surface water bodies they're shared
bodies of water they're public water
bodies and we drink them we water our
lawns with them we look at them we
recreate on them
so i think it's really important to have
this two or three year process
to make a well-informed decision about
something as important as the merrimack
river and certainly from a drinking
water standpoint seems like the way to
go 19 of 19 are the numbers i heard
that's a pretty good track record
um you know with my past experience in
non-profits uh i've i've learned that
when you get people involved then you've
got something that sticks so
a policy group can make a decision and
we can make a decree and
there you have it but if you want
long-term sustainability and stewardship
and citizen engagement
you start at the grassroots level and it
sounds like building up these advisory
committees and the community committees
the hearings and the involvement will
both inform
a sound policy but it also builds the
foundation of your leaders of folks to
help implement that at all parts of the
community moving forward
so um i very do much agree with
representative berry's intent uh i that
rang about me right out of the gate i
just think we should use the existing
process
and i believe it's under rsa 483
and the the process is under the colon
six section let's use that and let's put
that to work
and uh and steward the merrimack for the
next hundred years for all the people
that live along its banks and depend on
it
um so with that uh thank you very much
for your time and the opportunity to
speak and i'm open to any questions i'll
answer them if i can
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you chairman and with that
i will
close the hearing on house bill
1620.
thank you
and we are
lunches of lunch is upon us
uh
you can get back here at 10 after one
i think i can shave a little bit upward
like the
call the hearing to order house bill
an act permitting a dam
to be constructed
on big p porridge pond
and
chair
calls representative mcconkey
representative the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman chairman zillow
and steam members of uh resources
recreation development i'm here to
introduce house bill 1532
an act to permit a dam to be constructed
on big p porridge pond
for the record i hail from freedom i
represent the good people of carroll
county district three
i along with representative connerk and
mcaleery
who wanted also to be named as
co-sponsors on this but
by my submission time weren't able to do
so
i was approached by john and terry
cancel eric
to work
who were working with the porridge pond
association
who had concerns with fluctuating water
levels
to build a dam at the outlet of the big
pea porridge
pond to stabilize the operational level
of big p porridge pond
to benefit the watershed and aquatic
life
i
when i was first approached by this my
tenure here has always been in public
works and highways
and when someone comes forward and
proposes a dam
to me i
am not the most responsive person
knowing
what it's costing us now and how we're
not able to maintain what it is we have
as we got into this conversation further
i
started to become very comfortable with
this proposal
because it's a very small structure
number one that they're proposing
there are some pictures in one of your
handouts that was sent to you
of what this structure would look like a
number of boards being put in
and taken out each year that would
would
stabilize
the pond up above
the
it was what also made me eager to be
here
was that the
cost of this project whether it be the
construction the maintenance of this
project going forward
the cost to put boards in and out would
be borne by
the idlewice
board of commissioners i guess their
commissioners
and probably should explain that idawise
is a village district
in the town of madison
it has three water bodies in this
subdivision it's an old subdivision
from the 70s
and there are pictures and so forth
showing here
there
so cost was not an issue for me so as i
said that started making me more
comfortable
and things were moving along swimmingly
to say
the board of directors had a at a
meeting
were in favor of this proposal
and then
then all of a sudden uh there was a uh
letter uh that's mentioned in here in
the local paper
that uh stirred up uh some controversy
over this
and um opposition began to rise
and um when
as late as this morning
i had a conversation with
the chairman of the commissioners
and uh who had reached a had an
agreement
to uh to send to you in favor of this
proposal
but decided that they wanted to wait
until today's meeting before they sign
it that'd be jay buckley
and they're hoping that they're going to
feel good about this proposal once again
and they're starting to hear more in
favor than opposed to where they were
so people will be speaking behind me i
see jim here from the dam bureau and
others there's a letter from
commissioner scott from des in the
packet
that speaks of
his favor of this project
and
i just the last thing i'd like to add
before it's turned over
is i i needed to see buy in from all of
the parties before i brought this
forward and fish and games position
was that
go ahead and get the proposal going and
if the dam bureau and idawise and others
were in favor of it they'd be happy to
work with the parties going forward to
make sure
what's being proposed is good for the
environment
would meet their favor
so
with that
i think i will conclude my testimony and
allow you to have the opportunity
to speak with others that have more
knowledge
thank you is uh
any questions
for
the speaker by uh members of the board
of the committee
thank you
all right thank you
all right
i'm going to call
steve
doyon from the new hampshire department
of environmental services
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee
my name is steve doyle and i'm with des
i manage the
damn safety and inspection program for
mr gallagher who's also with me today
okay uh you have our letter of testimony
i'm going to summarize a few points so i
have additional letters of testimony if
you need them does anybody need any any
copies of that
we do have copies that okay very good
anybody hear me okay
okay
i wanted to start by summarizing the
figure that was included with the letter
of testimony i think it's fairly
straightforward but you can see the
three pawns here
just wanted to indicate that um
obviously big p
is to the uh to the east in the
photograph the largest water body and
the dam is to be constructed somewhere
very close to where the big pond outlets
into that stream channel that extends
between big p and middle p
middle p and little p are controlled by
a single dam that is at the outlet of
little
p um that that comes into play because
management occurs there that can affect
big p under certain conditions
uh that stream channel that connects
middle p to big p
uh does have some gradient in it so
to summarize then
um
the the dam at little p is also owned by
the uh the um
village district that idolized also just
if you didn't weren't aware of that
so as far as operations of the dam at
the outlet of little p
in dry conditions
or during dry down conditions
the
the gradient of the channel that
connects big p to middle p increases
which accelerates the discharge of water
out of big p
so i think during the drought conditions
that we've seen and under these
operations that can be conducted
downstream
there are the possibilities that big p
can drain prematurely in the summertime
you have spring flows that keep the
water up for a while and then over the
course of the dry summer
levels ebb so our understanding is that
the association wants to construct a
very small dam at the outlet of big
piece so that during those times not
only are they able to stabilize the
level of big p uh to
some elevation that we're not uh we know
we're not aware of that right now we
don't have a formal operating plan to
evaluate but we hope to get one so that
we can look at that but that and that
intent then is to make make sure that
they can keep a stable water level
uh the department well myself in
particular i've spoken to the folks who
are interested in building the sam john
and his wife
and we've imparted that
the most the least impact structure
would be
uh one that has a sill at the current
invert of the outlet brook
and stop log abutments at the ends of
the current width of the channel that
way there to maintain a higher water
level or stabilized water level all they
would need to do would be to put logs in
between those two concrete abutments
if for some reason they needed to
operate the dam for example during high
inflows they could remove all of the
logs and it would be just like returning
the outlet stream to its natural
condition there would be no impediments
in the brooks so that is our
recommendation for a structure and they
seem to be on board with that so that's
a good idea
it also allows them
to
in the fall conduct a drawdown so for
example if they determined if the
management plan that is ultimately
accepted causes the lake to rise a foot
for example
they have the ability in the fall so
they put it they would put in logs to
manage it to that level in the fall they
would take those logs out perhaps and
over the course of the winter the it
would be a natural stream again and then
it comes springtime they would put the
logs back in to achieve their summer
recreational pool
that is more beneficial than having a
permanent sill in the outlet brook
because that would be a permanent
impediment
uh an indication here in the letter uh
certainly there are other permits
involved here
the uh the dam would have to be approved
by the dam bureau there would have to be
a wetlands permit obviously in response
to an approval from the legislature to
have that happen
so there are many questions maybe that
still exists that would come out during
those permit
application processes perhaps for
wetlands which i think is also going to
consider issues that
associate with fisheries
and i did want to bring up a couple of
points that may not be in the letter
also
big pea porridge pond is a public water
body that is it's a
water body that is greater than 10 acres
in its natural state
so the state
holds a public trust interest in big
people
we haven't yet seen a final management
plan for
what
the associated association wants to do
at the level but certainly
those public trust rights could come
into play so we would just have to
evaluate and ensure that if maintaining
a stable water elevation restores the
pawn to the natural mean high water mark
which is the limit of states public
trust interest should be no problem
however if the association is interested
in raising the level higher than that
perhaps
then there comes an issue with uh
perhaps gaining water rights from
everybody who lives around the pond
which could be a daunting task not
impossible but it could be a difficult
thing but again it's to be determined
and the only other comment that i would
have
would be relative to the wording of the
legislation several years ago a similar
occurrence occurred at janus pond in
northwood
and the the
statute was written such that it said to
maintain a stable water elevation for
janus pond
but they also constructed their dam with
stop logs in it so that they could have
a drawdown
but because the legislation did not say
what because the legislation did say to
maintain a stable water level
i believe that organization had to come
back to the legislature to get the
wording amended so that they could have
a drawdown so i would just caution
those interest parties to make to take a
look at that to ensure that
you know their the wording of the
legislation is such that it allows them
that management flexibility
that's all i had
any questions by members of the
committee
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you mr dyan
for taking my question
um
you mentioned that the genus pond um
situation
called for a stable water level this
says a constant water level are you
saying that constant should be changed
for too stable or stable is not correct
either i believe the reference in the
legislation for genus pond uh implied
that the level would not change once the
dam was put in place the water level
would not be manipulated there was a
person who lived on the pond who who
took exception to the fact that when
they lowered the water body in the fall
that was contrary to the statute because
the statute said
the dam shall maintain a constant water
level
so that manipulation allowed the water
level to be lowered
and i'm saying that if that flexibility
is to be maintained at big p
perhaps the wording of this legislation
should maybe be altered to allow that
flexibility
follow-up yeah so you are saying it
should be you think that to make it
better it would be changed to something
like stable because stable is stable con
the same as kant i mean what do you see
as being the correct wording there what
would you recommend i would either
clarify the language in the statute to
allow
a drawdown for example or manipulation
of the level between parameters or to
take that statement out of the
legislation entirely
thank you
any other questions
well i just uh have
one question uh
is as the
as you're adjusting as they they plan
they i presume they're going to plan to
adjust the
the levels
uh
in the uh
in the in the big pond
and but also in this in the small pond
in this middle and the small pond by use
of the tube the two dams it's all going
to be done
uh
oh they're gonna it's gonna be kind of
synchronized by by one up my one group
you know i want to see one
one area one lake dominating the other
lakes
correct
my assumption would be that both groups
would be talking about operations that
exist but when the standard big p
porridge pond is built
each water body or i should say big p
versus little and middle should be able
to operate
with their own dams to achieve whatever
goals they have
but yes you're right i mean we are
certainly going to recommend that
that operations at each location be
coordinated between the parties
and
for
follow-up is that
uh reviewed by the dam bureau
the dam bureau requires that
low and significant and high hazard dams
have an operation and management plan
that includes telling us what has to
happen what what you intend to do to
operate your dam i don't think that
applies to non-menace dams but it could
i believe so we would probably request
that they submit a plan to us indicating
how they intend to operate it which
should then be available to anybody who
needs to look at it okay
thank
you
representative creighton for a question
thank you mr chair sir uh i appreciate
your testimony
my question really focuses on downstream
uh impact and that as i'm looking at the
map
uh between big and middle
um
once you put that down damn in there
what what happens to that stream
in if you looked at the impact on
uh
on the locals that are in and around
there on on the impact of that stream
downstream of the dam
the the simplest answer and the most
practical answer is that it shouldn't
make much difference because right now
when things get dry you're still getting
evaporation out of the out of big p
which is the biggest water
sink there
so when things dry up the brook dries up
now
to some degree
so with big p maintained a few inches
higher than it currently is with a stop
log
you're still going to get inflow equals
outflow until such time as there is no
inflow and evaporation is
controlling like during the droughts
that we had so there could be times and
there are times now where that stretch
of river river between big p and middle
p
is uh you know has very little water in
it
but that's no change
technically no change over what it is
today no
okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none
thank you very much
okay
uh i'll uh
somebody named john
from the uh
would like a last name
uh yeah i think you need to spell that
it's
it's three words put together
okay cancel a rich so cancel it
your clerk thanks you
all right
uh
and you you're
you represent the pea parge
p
p porridge pond sea porridge bond
association and
you support the bill
and
the floor is yours
thank you
thank you chairman
what i uh what i have here is this is um
part the pres i made the presentation
this is an hour-long presentation
reduce it to four minutes
four minutes mcconkey says no way so
four minutes really fast through
the primary purpose as as was speak
before is to maintain stable water
levels at the natural or slightly below
the natural level of the pond
that's it we're not raising the water
level so there should be less impact on
septic systems it's already where it
should be
so if we go through he showed the
picture of the ponds
i'm not going to go over that what they
did is in 1967 they built a dam at lower
p the intent was to have all these p all
these pawns at the same level so that
actual dam is higher than level at the
lowest point the control point of big p
okay so that's what they did
unfortunately when they got to big p
they stopped them from dredging things
out so that it's a great pond the state
stopped them they shouldn't touch it
we'll slip over this slide i'll go
really quickly this is the water level
in new hampshire it's pretty constant
about four inches per month is what you
get the big point about this slide is
that in april when you have your runoff
that's when your lake's the highest you
have to retain that water because after
that it declines your water's the same
your rain is the same the problem is you
cannot the level's going to drop simply
because of
plants trees
the land's dry
evaporation so we'll go to the next
slide
this is the slide loons and beavers okay
this is what's causing the fluctuation
so little p
has a loon this loon by the lpc john
cooley this productive rate of this loan
is 43 percent higher than the state
this is this is the core loan of the
territory of new hampshire
this has been very productive in
producing
the issue is is that little p
in order to do alone it's in the may
time frame
its nest is actually the place that nest
is actually 12 inches below
the top of the dam so they're draining
water instead like a normal path they
drain the water down to get to that loon
what that causes is fluctuation on our
end this is artificial man-made
fluctuation
animals aren't used to that the second
part is beavers every one to four years
we have a beaver a beaver builds up in
our stream up near big p
every four years we take it down well
what happens with the beaver our water
level goes up with the beaver dam and
then it gets taken down that's a foot
loss so here we are here's the loon
throughout the years beaver dam loss
loon throughout the years beaver dam
loss we're getting so much fluctuation
on our water levels at big p
let's take a look at the chart the next
one this is an illustration i actually
took this out of
winnipesaukee this is theirs so the side
is not the actual water level
but the chart that i wrote in represents
the actual drop of water level so in
this illustration you can see
water has a natural ability in the
runoff early spring you try to get your
water up to your highest level that you
want to reach
that's where you want it because after
that it's just going to drain the rain
comes it's not you're not going to keep
it
during that time
during the may to
june july
extremely important to maintain solid
stable water levels
creatures frogs amphibians laying eggs
the fish are coming in nesting close to
shore that shoreline of 0 to 15 feet is
massive to the health of ponds and lakes
you have to maintain that you have to
let them do it what happens is if you
look on the side vdoe
environmental penny did an observation
and tract here we are first this is what
little p does a board's already out
early during
during the uh winter and fall
early spring at this time if you look at
the 17th of may they remove a second
board that's 20 inches they're trying to
take off the water level they're not
trying to keep a high level they're
trying to get it down 12 inches what
happened to us we observed through the
what was observed for the environmental
committee is that between 517 the time
they took that board out our water at
big p
dropped nine inches in ten days
this is during prime reproduction of
amphibians fish and everything we're
fluctuating
this doesn't always happen because once
again we get that beaver dam that we
love i love the beaver dam it protects
us slightly but then we get this waffle
beaver dam's gone it comes up protects
us
drops every four years we can't leave
the beaver dam up there because um they
can't survive you have to take them out
they just want to control more water
next slide i'm going to skip impact and
skip the pitcher
mouth of damp has been talked about
here's the creek picture of it
as as he mentioned there's actually used
to be a screen a fish screen in here
that was two two feet high
in this stream and underneath is a
cement um you can't see it but there's
suspense slab that's where we want the
dam
so here's a picture this was sent from
the dan bureau
this picture shows the cement structure
this is a different place this is jensen
but this is a
an example of what it could look like
just cement things on the side of the
brook and you have boards in it
and you can take the boards out for the
fall draw down and so lastly
although the last part
is
the dam itself we're looking at 18
inches 12 inches it depends this is
where we really really beg
we've been trying to do this for five
years we beg fish and game to come in
and help us through this and the dam
bureau what
all we care about is what's best for the
lake
they'll help us determine what that
level should be for the aquatic life and
really be happy to have them involved
so last again it's to maintain water
levels kind of make it more steady
during those fluctuations these are
artificial fluctuations every biologist
everyone talks about it the fish can
handle the rain the small rains the
schedules they cannot handle the
manual fluctuations as well as the big
drops on the beaver dams so that
concludes my quick presentation for the
hour
i'm just going to grab a little water
but go ahead
okay
any questions for members of the board
representative egan thank you mr chair
thank you sir for taking my question you
referenced a few times they so is there
a
specific community group environmental
group that will oversee
when the boards go in when the boards go
out monitors the water monitors the
the level and who is that and how does
that process work
um there's there's two parts there's
there's a dam at little p and that's
controlled as he mentioned by the
village district of idaho ice what
happened is they formed a community
around this mountain area for the lakes
um
the village district controls their so
they're dropping it for the loons
they're trying to maintain it but it
keeps changing over the years because
commissioners change as far as this goes
our bill says we are i'm actually
actually talk after talking to a lot of
people on the lake and stuff
we're potentially thinking
to have the village district of idaho
ice control we think that that might be
a better approach
ours is not to my job in our group's job
we want stable water levels we feel that
in that combination we might be best to
relieve ourselves from this and have the
village district control it
with that said a lot of people felt that
the village district because of
fluctuation in kind of in-road fights of
protecting the loans and protecting the
water
we would recommend we want it to be
stable we we prefer it to be in and then
maybe as steve recommended talk to the
danbury what we can do so that we're not
constantly moving for the for the
fluctuations we really want it stable so
our group can say hey people aren't
messing with this we just get into that
natural level
and then after take it out they did he
did recommend because of flooding and
stuff to take it out for the fall
drawdown
that is my approach and that that's what
after talking to people i would
recommend now that i've i've talked to
people
that would cause a another change
in the proposal
any other questions oh just follow up
just to clarify so you're talking about
an amendment to the bill to change who
would oversee
if if i could i'd prefer my legislation
who's representing the bill to address
that
i'm sorry the committee who is
addressing that okay perfect thank you
i'm sorry
no
thank you sir any uh
anyone else
thank you very much
chair recognizes
peter cunn
kond is it our
rot r-a-t
well uh
not having fun reading names
uh she and you you were in opposition i
am
the floor is yours now just give your
name and your address
my name is peter condra and i live on
the pond at 89 first meadow road
and i've lived there now for a few years
there are likely 70 plus households that
border the pond
and many more people that use it for
recreational purposes
for a small group five as of now such as
this to claim they are acting for the
majority
is far from the case
i attended their zoom meeting and came
away very uneasy about what they are
proposing
there is insufficient data to support
their claims
something that should be strongly
considered
it seems the main driving force for this
request is that the vdoe the village
district of idaho ice
does not properly control their dam
this dam could turn into the same
situation
with the majority of our pond having no
say over water levels
this group of the minority wants to
assume the role of controlling the dam
and based on the history of what has
gone on with vdoe
this is a terrible idea
the ramifications of playing with water
levels
can be very far-reaching in ways that we
cannot predict
more study needs to be done before this
is ever going to be considered a good
idea
the pond has survived without our
intervention for thousands of years
just because we had a recent drought
problem
as did the rest of the northeast
this seems to be a rush to judgment
there are too many events that could
happen with this very few of them would
be good
if due to this proposed dam the pond
becomes contaminated forever
who is responsible
if the dam breaches and floods
100 plus homes downstream
who's responsible
if these people in control of the dam
for some reason leave the area
who's responsible
who even owns the dam
and i think they address that that they
they're trying to make the vdoe take
that over but
at the zoom meeting it was very unclear
there was a lot of
very unclear information that
just left me
in the
trust me department and i'm not filled
with trust here there are way too many
questions and not enough answers and i
would urge you to please vote against
this proposal
any questions by members of the
committee
representative huff
thank you mr chairman thank you for
coming and testifying um my question is
you obviously live there yes
um and i'm assuming it's a very nice
place i love it
so my question is
um
as you alluded to it's been there for a
long time
and it uh
all of the life that is around that pond
seems to be there
i don't understand
why the
need for a specific level
i don't know if you know the answer to
that but
i i think
it's maybe i'm going on for a while but
um
there's certain
changes that occurs with with different
levels at different times of the year
and we've all been experienced at this
drought i mean this summer everyone
knows it was bad
water levels were down they came back up
i mean this happens we can't
i don't think we need to to play god
here i think we should let
let this pond happen i mean i don't know
if that really answers your question but
um
maintaining the water levels i think
on the service is a great idea i suppose
but what's that level who who determines
that is there science involved we can't
just
jump in and say i think this is what it
should be
when really
that is what it should be
thank you thank you
anyone else from the committee
representative creighton followed by
representative smith
thank you mr chairman sir i appreciate
your your testimony and and
this is a difficult issue
um
i'm trying to tie together your
testimony with the picture and the
previous testimony
so the the dam that i that was
demonstrated as what they want to put in
there was less than 18 inches tall
and it was controlled by logs
that come in and come out fairly easily
apparently you know just looking at the
picture they just come out of little
channels
so
i'm not sure what this i mean it's not
like you're putting the hoover dam in
there oh no so the danger to the hundred
towns downstream
how do you see that because i mean if
it's at a normal level whatever level
that is
then that whatever came down is going to
be
at a normal amount of flow through there
well
if we go with your 18-inch measurement
you would just mention it let me just by
looking at the picture i know and that
was that was a proposal that i i think
they're thinking about
um
even if it's six or eight inches if you
if you
take the size of that pond which i'm not
i'm thinking 70 80 acres it's it's big
and you multiply that by six inches of
depth of water and that board breaks and
that all goes at one time
that's a lot of water
it would you know
that's obviously worse case scenario but
i'm just saying it's potential could
happen i think
we really need to
study this a lot more
before we jump into putting a dam there
thank you sir
uh representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um when
uh mr doyen doyen spoke from uh
des the dam bureau
he stated that most likely
this
project would require a management plan
would that make you feel any more
comfortable i'm not exactly sure what a
management plan would entail but would
that make you feel like things were
going in a good direction and all the
permitting would have to happen too
i think
well possibly but i think what really
needs to happen is a study would need to
be done
on
at least the septic system situation
around the pond um
every there's a lot of houses
lake level or just you know three feet
above lake level let's say that have
older septic systems
and i i i know the current law requires
you to have four feet of
um
depth in your sept in your leech field
to a water table
and many of them don't even have that
now
if we
constantly keep that water level there
where don't let it go down in the summer
don't let stuff drain down we're asking
for leachate to go into the pond and
we're asking for trouble
thank you
representative harp for question
thank you sir for taking my question um
i had a question about who you were and
if you're related to shauna condratt
the president i am
her husband okay because i didn't know
the spelling of your name and are you a
member of the
p big p parridge watershed preservation
association i am
okay did they send you here to speak on
their behalf they did not i'm speaking
on my own
okay thank you she will be speaking
later oh she's here i don't see the
cards okay thank you very much
any other questions
representative
post then representative cohen
thank you mr chairman and thank you
today i just wanted to confirm you did
send a letter to us in our
legislative email i did
thank you
representative cohen
thank you for taking my question i'm
just curious as a homeowner there you're
a it's a two-part question so follow are
you a year-round homeowner
and if so what happens in the summer
recreation
your question on the second part of that
so
could you speak into the microphone
please
i'm sorry i didn't understand the second
part of that question
yeah both of you so
can you hear me okay now uh excuse me
representative post please shut off your
mic
and me
second part of the question was
i'm assuming that a a large part of the
recreation of living on that pond is
summer related activity
and how will a dam being installed
negatively
affect your summer enjoyment and others
homeowners summer enjoyment of the pond
as far as recreation i don't suppose it
would
but
i
mentioned earlier i think scientifically
we need to tread lightly here
thank you
any other questions
if if not
thank you very much
thank you
speaking in support of the bill
uh
nordell gagnon
good afternoon
nordell gagnon i live at 133 pondwood
drive
30-year resident year-round resident of
the pond
i've got a photograph here if i could
show you guys
you get a different perspective of the
pond and i'll tell you my spiel
you can see the mountains in the back
around here
so
i represent a
1200 feet of frontage on the north shore
of the pond and 50 acres on the slope
here coming in with two hydrox streams
coming into the pond
and
this area here
is the literal zone on this side the
fishery and of the uh
the habitat for all the poliwogs the
frogs the fish
that the loons and the
larger fish eat
so when that water has been drained the
last 10 years
the uh the water has receded at the
wrong time on an irregular basis it has
killed all of the egg nesting
along this shore that i see i visually
see
so the pond is in dire straits as of the
last 10 years
at one point
we have an ice fishing derby they're
catching little fish like this
okay
ten years ago the kids were bringing me
fish with bellies hanging down in the
middle
tow trout
that aren't in there anymore so the
fishery i have visually seen
drop down
i do manage the loons on big p porch
we have not had a chick
in eight years
we had an egg last year it was predated
but that fluctuation of that drawdown of
the water from the other ponds south of
us
not coordinated with anybody
has affected our loon nest we do we did
try a floating raft just to
mitigate that but there are many
problems with
that water level coming up and down
coming up and down and is
that's the key i think the dam
management is the key to this problem
on the idlewise side they're not
coordinating anything with us so you can
see the great pond here
the middle pond and there's the little
dam on this farther over there they're
lowering that level but they're really
lowering our level here and this affects
major watershed
and the other thing is yeah we are a
summer recreation
i've met people from all over the
country and all over the world on the
pond in 30 years
that pond was down you did we have a
boat ramp without a state boat ramp to
get your boat back in
you can't get a boat in
and there was a there actually there was
a rescue i was involved in of the 80
year old man in a boat they couldn't get
the fire department couldn't get the
raft in because that water had been
drawn down and it never
once that water gets drawn down at that
time for the other ponds it never
recoups for the whole season so this in
this past decade it's been a very
drastic
actions here with the with the fishery
is that your testimony yes okay
any questions
of the speakers
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh who who is responsible for the damn
uh the damn levels changing in the dam
that is presently
distance the village district of idol
wise which owns two ponds that are not
state ponds in their district it was
started as a vacation home
place back in the 70s
our big pond connects to theirs
so there are two uneducated people a
road maintenance man and a commissioner
who has who has great interest in his
loon at his house which had a camera on
which has been taken off by loon
preservation
so at his whim
he would take the boards out of the dam
at the
damn flow
i have visually seen it
happen when those boards go out our lake
goes down and then it never quite
recoups
once they do that so they're not
there it's kind of like a wild west
situation they're not
they're doing it at their whim
that has been our major problem
thank you
president creighton
thank you sir i'm sorry i appreciate
your testimony we've heard testimony
that
putting a dam in would endanger
downstream based on the
um potential for a flood coming down
that people have not been informed about
this and it hasn't gone through
a process
and
that there are other challenges how
would you respond to that
the lay of the land and the slope of the
land is so mild that it would
probably take a tsunami to cause any
damage which is highly unlikely
and there is plenty it is not it is not
like it's a narrow canyon from the
outflow of the great pond into the
middle it's it's very
spread out like a parking lot there
there are trees or woods in there but
it's it's a flowing valley so it's not a
pitched canyon like you'd see
you know in the american west where
everything just comes down at once so
if there was ever and we've had heavy
rains and i i've there's never been been
a problem that i have seen
on that side
any other questions
if not
thank you very much thank you for your
time
okay
uh
let's say
in opposition shawna kondrat
from madison uh
madison yep okay
good afternoon
um
i just want to preface this with
i am not an expert by any means i am not
comfortable being in this position
so bear with me
i'm shauna conrad i'm a resident at
89 first meadow road in madison i'm the
current president of the big p porridge
watershed preservation association which
is a new hampshire registered 501c
corporation with over 70 members
that has been working since 2018 to
protect improve and preserve the
watershed and water quality of the lake
to save its pristine
beauty most recently we have been
working to minimize road runoff from the
steep dirt roads surrounding the pond
that fills the inlet and has destroyed a
working wetland which abuts my property
my husband's property off allard hill
town line and brenna roads in both
madison and conway
we're working closely with rockhouse
mountain homeowners association the new
hampshire des
and towns of madison and conway to
address the
situation in a rational scientifically
based manner
the members and board of the association
became aware of the introduction of hb
1532 a few days ago
and only through an article in the
conway daily sun we are not affiliated
with the association referenced in hb
1532 and we had no knowledge of its
existence
i'd just like to
reference what
representative mcconkey said earlier
about he thought he had all this support
and then suddenly there was an article
in the paper and things changed that's
because none of us knew about this
this bill
now this new association which is formed
by five people has taken these steps
despite the fact that there are
approximately 70 waterfront homes on big
p
460 additional homes in idlewise and
about 108 in raucous mountain homeowners
association that all have rights to
enjoy this pond
the lack of transparency and
communication with affected homeowners
is extremely disturbing
an initial analysis by our wetland
experts has indicated that there are a
number of questions regarding the
impacts of a dam at the outlet of big p
including questions about ongoing
effects on fishing amphibians water
quality grandfathered septic systems
along the lakefront etc
there has been no comprehensive
professional ecological impact
evaluation completed to assess these
issues
big p porridge pond is a designated
great pond owned by as you know the
citizens of new hampshire in this
legislation would authorize a select
group of individuals individuals to
build and operate a dam affecting the
entire pond without professional
understanding and oversight
i find that disturbing regardless of
perhaps the best intentions management
downstream at the dam on little p as it
has been discussed has revealed just how
damaging to the environment such a
situation can be
i am surprised i'm probably not supposed
to say this
i am surprised by the position this
afternoon of the nhges who spoke earlier
representative who spoke earlier
because my understanding was
nhdes has been trying to dismantle the
dams there's about five thousand dams in
new hampshire
and they're working at taking
some of them out not building new dams
and i could be wrong
but i i know the nhdes
has a different opinion that was
people there have a different opinion
that was presented earlier
in conclusion the big p porridge
watershed preservation association
recommends that this bill be classified
inexpedient to legislate and i thank you
for your consideration and listening to
my wobbly voice
thank you very much
is there any questions for members of
the
committee
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so you
my understanding from what you just said
is that you were on big p porridge pond
correct
and those in favor are also on big p
porridge pond correct okay
thank you you're welcome
i guess thank you very much i don't see
any other
any other questions thank you very much
for your testimony thank you
chair calls
uh in support of the bill terry
cancellaric
that's pretty good
i learned
fast
same spelling as his
um thank you very much for um
your attention and your time today i
appreciate it
the idlewise side drive of a big p has a
more gradual slope
to it than the allard hill side on the
other side of the pond has which has a
deeper you know a deeper a steeper slope
so the impact of declining water levels
is more direct more dramatic on the
gradual slope side
our neighbor wooda mcniven fixes a
yardstick to his dock so we can observe
the decline in water levels in the
spring
a two inch decline in water levels
results in a foot of extra shore
so you can see if we lose six to eight
or even as much as 10 inches of the
snowmelt and the runoff
we the waters recede dramatically and
why this is important i'll get to it
i'm also speaking on behalf of lindsay
wedge her family has owned a house on
big p for close to 30 years
she
up until recently was a specialist at
the new england aquarium
her husband is an expert in the fishes
department at the new england aquarium
she spoke at our monday meeting and she
has spoken in the past to the village
district of idaho weiss's commissioners
at their
damn management meeting
damn management policy meetings um she
is for this damn i don't want to speak
for her but she is
she gave me some slides that you'll see
in here this one that says impacting
from just the impact from disturbing
water levels these were supplied by
lindsay so i'm going to
read from the notes that she provided to
me
and it's about the impact of the water
levels okay
so fluctuating water levels on the
lakeshore and on the literal zone the
littoral zone is the area from the
lakeshore out to about 15 feet depth of
water
this area
is vital to a pond it's prime breeding
and nesting grounds for fish amphibians
and other wildlife many fish inhabit the
literal zone
for part of if not their entire life
cycle the species in these zones have
evolved to the natural cycles of water
level fluctuations artificial
fluctuations however create stress on
those species and on the entire biome
when the literal zone is disrupted and
again that's from the shore 15 feet out
it decreases the availability of
adequate habitat
disrupts organisms that are spawning
nesting and occupying that zone and
increases the mortality rate
every spring just as those or just when
those organ organisms are spawning and
nesting the vdoe pulls two
10 inch boards
from the dam at little p excuse me
causing big p to lose most of that snow
melt and run off
please turn to the one that says if you
if you have it in front of you the
picture says a million words
okay the pitcher to the left is of the
shoreline on an undeveloped lot next to
our house
prior to the drawdown the water reaches
to the left edge of that pitcher
as the water recedes the aquatic plants
and fishness are exposed
the middle pitcher is of the shoreline
that's approximately 300 feet down from
the first pitcher and is taken from our
neighbor's dock
those rocks
are usually underwater before the
drawdown
those residents the mcnivens have been
on the pond for close to 40 years
the picture on the right is the
shoreline in front of our house most of
it's usually under water
you'll see that it's not we often see
fish nest among those plants that are
now on dry grant dry ground
and we have watched often
watch some of those fish struggle as the
water recedes
lower water levels also results in
warmer warmer warmer water temperature
which encourages algae and bacteria
growth when the algae dies it decomposes
and consumes oxygen dissolved that's
been dissolved in the water and needed
by fish and other aquatic life to
breathe
if enough oxygen is removed so that area
cannot sustain life you have a dead zone
occur
now rather than a gradual decline in the
accumulated snowmelt and runoff over the
course of several months which you would
have if there wasn't a dam at little p
the drawdown in late april may causes
big p to fall to its lowest possible
point when the water flowing through the
banford brook
can slows considerably just as it heads
into the hottest driest months
of the year when natural evaporation is
at its highest and rainfall is at its
lowest in the time of drought
the shore can look like this
this is the high water mark
this is like where the water is
again the high water mark is right there
and this is where the water is
the porridge ponds used to be teeming
with fish and bullfrogs in the spring
if you turn to the next uh wait
sorry before you'll see my cute kid
holding a bullfrog pollywog in a plastic
container now
he was really cute then now he's a
teenager and 17. um
so do you used to be teeming with these
large bullfrog tadpoles in the spring
and for some time frog now for some time
frog populations actually have been on
the decline in many areas for unknown
reasons but climate change land develop
are factors but the frogs on big p
didn't disappear gradually
one year they were there the next year
they were gone
what happened
the board of commissioners acknowledged
at the august dam policy meeting that
the previous board of commissioners
didn't know that there was a fish and
game guideline that advised
fishing finishing fall drawdowns before
october 15th
in order to protect hibernating
amphibians that had boiled in the
substrate in 2015 2016 i don't know the
precise year was one of those there was
a very late and significant fall
drawdown
it froze the substrate
and killed the frogs the frogs now are
slowly beginning to recover but its
numbers are still far short of what they
once were
this brings me to the board of
commissioners
there have been six different boards in
six years
there'll be a seventh board in march
there'll be an eighth board next year
often there's a new dam management
policy put in place by the new board
there was last year
it's rare that a policy is followed but
it's hard to know if it's being followed
because no log is kept
of the removal and replacement of the
boards at the dam at little p
the dpw removed a 10 inch board in
december this past december because of
ice jams at little p
they informed the dam bureau who okayed
the release of water conditioned that
the 10 inch board be replaced with a
six-inch board
it is now late january and that has yet
to be done
now while the current damp policy policy
is supposed to stand for five years
there are already a number of warrant
articles proposed by one commissioner
mike smith one of which would put him
solely in charge of the dam
this commissioner has been on
commissioner on and off for 16 years
now as previously mentioned there's been
an established pair of successful loons
very close to his property on a marshy
spot
a few times the nest was flooded by
heavy rains and the eggs were lost
to protect that loon nest he put in
place the dam management policy i
believe is like 2012 2013 around there
sometime
to conduct an early spring drawdown to a
co which was accomplished by removing
the two 10 inch boards from the dam
according to the loon preservation
committee the porridge ponds are the
only bodies of water in the entire state
of new hampshire who preemptively lower
water levels ahead of loon nesting
season and this is an addition
to the fall
now for this isn't for me this this
isn't about recreation this is about
uh
preserving
the
preserving the pond quality
so that we can have a healthy pond
i had another point i just lost it
and as far as like our members
membership right now our membership is
low but we do have a broad support from
at least 12
families on big p and they've written to
you in support
i do want to point out one thing and
that was mr mcconkey raised this article
that was written in the conway daily sun
a few days ago
if i can find my notes
that article if it was read was poorly
written there was not one fact about big
p in it other than that this meeting was
being held today
mr anglers angers who wrote the article
encouraged people to write in to oppose
a dam i wrote to the owner of the conway
daily sun about the lack of research
that went into his article
here is mark gearing's email response to
me
columns like phishing and hiking are
written by experts on their subjects we
have never had a need to fact check
in fact this is the first time i can
remember in 30 years
a contributor is off base
in fact he's already sent me a letter of
apology
so the owners of the conway daily sun
acknowledged that this columnist was off
base but the damage had been done that
article spurred other people to write to
the vdoe commissioners in opposition to
the dam
now i don't i don't really want to be
here today i'm sure
but after nine years of naively hoping
the next board would be more responsible
with the
dam at little p
and after nine years of watching big p
wildlife and waters degrade
i couldn't stand by and do nothing it's
not my nature
no one came forth with the solution we
could see no other solution than a very
small non-menacing dam to isolate big p
from the vagaries of the board of
commissioners and to protect its waters
and wildlife
the dam bureau had recommended a dam
fish and game was open to the idea the
loon preservation committee has
expressed support
to protect the waters and the wildlife
of big p
we gain nothing but a healthy pond
so actually we gained quite a bit thank
you for your time
any questions by members of the board
representative smith and well
representative smith and representative
gould
thank you mr chair um you mentioned that
you have 12 families on big p in support
of this yes how many um homes families
are there on big p
oh gosh um shawna might know the answer
to that one i would say
70.
thank you
representative gould okay thank you mr
chairman and thank you uh for coming to
testify and i don't know if
this is the proper question for you or
maybe someone else who has already
testified i'm not sure but i'm just
wondering what the situation of these
pawns would be
if there were no dams and left in the
natural state as they were say 200 years
ago oh my god that's what i'm wondering
what would be happening in that
situation so i wasn't here 200 years ago
but i can make an attempt at that
um as was mentioned there was a company
great northern development company back
in the late 60s that found this piece
gorgeous piece of land decided to make
it um
a vacation rental place for
uh affluent people from massachusetts or
rhode island or wherever they may have
been
but there was probably wasn't enough
waterfront so they decided
big peanut always been always been there
and then there was a creek banford creek
that had like flowed down
like a creek would and to uh my
understanding is they they put a dam
into um
they put a dam up to create little p and
middle pay
so if 200 years ago if you were to take
the dam out those small ponds those
smaller pawns would go away but big p
would remain
representative creighton yeah thank you
sir thank you for your testimony ma'am
um
under your understanding and you talked
about the control
in the committee that controls the lower
p dam
so
if this dam went in who would control it
do you know what's the plan for
controlling it
and how is the control of that any
better managed
than the lower one i mean is it going to
be the same committee different
committee what's their expertise why are
they more
expert to to do that
thank you for that question um so it
would be the same board of commissioners
they would have different dm operating
policies and manuals the motivations too
are different right so the motivation
the small at the small p at the small p
dam
is to expose this one marshy spot and in
order to do that
they have to um
take a lot of boards out of the dam to
lower the water level low enough for for
big p
our goal here is to maintain a stable
water level the level it would be at
or slightly less than this if there was
no dam at big p
so so the motivations are different at
big p we would want to be able to
maintain a more stable level so that we
can have loans while at lower p they
would probably they would they would
continue to um
draw that down
okay but it's just this is this will be
our commission yeah it's the same
commissioners yes but again different dm
operating policies
um different um
different motivation
okay and for a follow answer
we're a follow-on so
uh
i'm just trying to track
um numbers so there's 12 of 70 people
opposed
well there's 12 right now 12 right now
so okay and we had bear with me one
second so we've had testimony
that
the people around the lake that had
and there were three different
communities with different you know up
to 600 different folks had not been
notified so how how are these 12 people
notified everyone else not notified or
what's been the outreach yeah to the
community to get feedback are you
talking about the meeting we held on
monday or just talking just in general i
mean we've got clearly people in this
room that feel like they had no
notification and we have other people
who are
obviously well informed and been
involved with this
from the beginning so i'm just trying to
understand how you
go from being uninformed to being an
expert
and what that process was thank you
thank you so this this is actually uh
something that we had you know been
talking to
fish and game in the new hampshire um
dan bureau about for i don't know five
years charlie krautman before we talked
with mr doyan and um carol henderson at
fish and game so they're aware of this
situation
now as far as
we
received
uh
unanimous support from the village
district of idaho commissioners in
august to explore the possibility of a
legislative bill for a dam for little p
i mean for big p excuse me
so everything so that was just in late
you know mid august
everything happened pretty quickly
this is not our area of expertise so we
consulted a lawyer because this is not
my area of expertise so it's jason
reamers of bcm environmental and land
law right here in concord
the first test was to find a sponsor
jason reached out to mark mcconkey and
mark agreed after review agreed to
sponsor a bill and suggested we enlist
other representatives some of this takes
a little bit of time
now too the the issue of fluctuating
water levels and of the prospect of
raising a dam had been raised many times
at various uh vdoe commissioners meeting
and again at the dam management policy
meeting
in august
and those are open to the public anyone
can go to those
now at the beginning of november
november we knew we needed to have a
meeting with all affected residents
unfortunate circumstances caused my
husband to be away from his home and
family
for four to five weeks
returning right before christmas
so that sort of uh waylaid us a little
bit the hearing that was scheduled this
hearing right here was scheduled sooner
than we expected and as soon as mr
mcconkie notified us on monday january
10th we set up a meeting as quickly as
we could and notified as many residents
as we had email addresses for
that was uh january and we had the
meeting on january 7. yes we wish we had
been able to give more notice and reach
more people and for that we have
apologize
representative post for question thank
you mr chairman and thank you for your
testimony today um i have a question if
the
if the dam on little p
was not
putting in and taking out would that
preclude you from wanting to put a dam
on big p absolutely
so why are you in support of the dam
and rather
than
removing the other dam or oh you can't
remove the other dam because then you do
away with little p and middle p
so that that dam has been there for a
while that dam's been there since the
late 1960s and the
little p and middle p are only there
because of that dam
right okay so that's why that dam can't
be removed that dam is owned by the
village district of idaho ice it is
controlled by the three commissioners
a follow-up
for a follow-up
so
so with
with the dam that's going to go in place
if it gets through
you would still go to the same people
even though knowing
that
the problems they've caused you wouldn't
do something separate you wouldn't be
looking for a separate
group and would you not
be looking for more support
from
the homeowners um great question thank
you we're open to any and all
we're looking for the best possible
solution to this problem now whether
that's the vdoe owning the dam and
controlling the dam
you know maybe maybe it's the vdoe
owning the dam but not but not having
the control of the dam and maybe a
committee is formed that will have input
into that and
if that committee was formed we would
seek a really broad audience we we have
a wetlands specialist on big p who would
be a part of that we have lindsey and
david wedge again
with the new england aquarium
who who one is an expert in the fishes
department
you're kind of going
off
basically
what you're saying is simply if the dam
goes up on big p
the dam on little p
is really irrelevant
that's what i'm saying okay
you said it much shorter than i did any
other question
from the from the
committee if not thank you very much
all right
keep
continuing through
victoria
cortland
cortland cortland
uh
three minutes
please
turn your
thing on
is it on okay thank you thank you for
the opportunity to speak
uh as an ecologically minded shoreline
homeowner i have worked with the new
hampshire lakes association to make the
necessary changes
to my property in order to attain lake
smart status
this would not have been possible
without the help of my generous friends
some of whom are here today with various
perspectives on the bill before us
i feel confident that all of my
neighbors are concerned with the health
of the pond and want to take the steps
necessary to restore and conserve its
ecosystem
even though we may have differing
viewpoints on how to achieve that goal
nevertheless i am optimistic that we can
come together when we make decisions
informed by science to determine the
best path forward
only last thursday did i learn of the
proposed house bill 1532 through an
email invitation to a zoom meeting on
the following monday
hosted by two of the five members of the
big p porridge pond association
this small group of part-time residents
is a different organization than the big
p porge pond preservation association of
which i am a member the latter holds 501
c 3 status and is managed by a full
board
including
two wetland scientists
which serves a 70 person membership that
continues to increase
this just as an aside this organization
also has developed relationships across
the region with
the town and
other like des and other organizat
organizations in order to
um
work uh on a solution for the runoff
coming from rock house mountain
so today i am here to propose that if
this bill is not killed by opposition it
should be amended to authorize the
formerly incorporated non-profit big p
porridge pond preservation association
which represents a majority of the
shoreline and water watershed residents
as the entity that may construct and
manage a dam on the pond
in i i also want to add that um the
village district of idaho ice
um
the the land within the village district
is a minority of the shoreline on big p
port
um so in the several days since i
learned of the bill i have not had
adequate time to do enough research to
to determine whether a dam would aid or
harm big p
i understand the water quality issues
faced by the pond are complex due to a
variety of environmental pressures and
pollutants
when it comes to the topic of water
fluctuation a study was conducted by
wetland scientists that determined it is
physically impossible for the little p
porridge pond dam to cause a drop of
more than six inches in big p
and even then in only limited
circumstances
therefore i fear that adding a dam to
solve the problem of mismanagement of
another dam downstream may be a
short-sighted solution
during a time in history when we can be
far more innovative in our approaches to
wetland restoration and conservation
in the past couple of days i have come
to understand that as a great pond big p
is held in public trust and that the new
hampshire legislature enacted statutes
for the state's department of
environmental services to regulate
activities that take place within that
trust
the the 1532 bill proposal needs to be
carefully examined by specialized
bureaus in the des because a dam that
controls water levels at big p will have
impacts on grandfathered septic systems
along the waterfront
overall water quality
and the fish amphibians loons and eagles
and other animals including humans
that depend on a healthy ecosystem
currently there has been no professional
ecological impact evaluation completed
to assess
these concerns and i believe doing so is
necessary to proceed
it if it turns out that a dam is an
appropriate solution
let's take the time to do it right so
that we are not in a position of having
to remediate further ecological damage
in the future to an already overburdened
pond i did want to add another
couple of sentences to what i have
written here which is that most of the
testimony today has
included
frustration over how the village
district of idawes manages
and operates the little p porridge pond
dam
and it doesn't make any sense to me that
um
they would be that the village district
of idaho ice would be
nominated to
control and manage
this dam if they haven't been able to do
an adequate job of the other one
that's why
again i think that
it makes more sense to amend the bill
to
make sure that
the
construction and management of
any proposed dam
would uh fall
to
organizations like like
the big p porridge pond preservation
association which is already
incorporated nonprofit and with the
oversight of des and um
and perhaps another professional
organization but not a group of um
of the five and growing um
uh
big p porridge pond association alone
because they do not represent
this um
bigger group of people thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony any uh
any questions from the uh from the
committee
representative post
thank you very much for taking my
question again i just wanted to know if
you could send us your testimony i
didn't see it in my
inbox yes absolutely i can do that um
immediately after this thank you
anyway anyone else
i got one more
thank you very much thank you
dennis
deshane
uh
uh ten
ten minutes not
hardly uh
put it this way
you mean
yeah
yeah put your button on but uh all right
you can see if you can do it in
four minutes i'll try to do it in like
two no
it would be appreciated we're only
running well forget it i'll be real fast
i'm 72 years old i've been there 72
years i've seen everything one of the
original seven camps on the lake
i took over the loons for a guy named
bill mclean
many years ago when i was about 18. he
couldn't do it no more i said i take
care of it so i raised at least
for 40 years we always had two
two baby loons
or one or two always
we don't have them no more
the last loons i think was
about eight years ago
um this pond needs
it needs water in it in the spring the
reason i i know this uh many years ago
i'm i'm probably 30 years old i'm really
interested in the porn i go
i see the game wardens out there it was
the biologist the guy was out there with
two sane nets i i paddled out
i said what are you what are you doing
he goes i'm checking the lake
for for the warm water species i said
how i said okay
he said what how's the lake i said
what's the lake look like so this lake
is in the top 10 percent of the state he
goes see and i said why is it like that
he goes see how this
all around the edge of this lake
it's all right up into the tree into the
bushes
in the spring which is right where it
needs to be
all the fish all the way around go spawn
they get protected
as the summer goes on it goes down
it goes okay that's it so that lake was
vibrant smell you could look out on that
pond and see
50 75 schools of smelt out on that lake
we've caught fish in that lake for years
like
big fish big brown trout
so anyways
we need the high water in the spring it
can go down i mean it go down get people
because they want to swim they want to
have beaches no problem but we need it
in the spring
um by the way
a comment about who runs the dam
it can't be the idol ice people
they have a big hole in their dam right
now about six feet down
they can't be relied on and i agree
completely with victoria if this dam is
there
we need dynamic
operation of it when we get a rain we
need a couple inches of water get a
board in there and keep that water
because if it goes down we'd have no
control over it
um
that's about the best i can say the as
far as the fish and game department
there there's a boat ramp but
i i'm a fisherman i've been a fisherman
my whole life anna you know
i'm a fisheries guy you can't get a boat
in there in in august there's no water
and in fact couple years ago when we had
the bad one i'd say four to five years
ago that water was down at least
i'm gonna say a foot and a half my boat
was right on the gravel i'd never seen
that and by the way i think and i don't
know for sure but i think our pond is
about a foot and a half it should be a
foot and a half higher than than the
middle
middle dam where we are definitely
higher
and it's got to be kept up there and
like
you said or victoria said
um
she thinks it's a little lower i i'm
pretty sure it's higher
we need to keep it up in that level and
i don't see any reason why all the
people around the pond we can't come to
a happy happy conclusion about what's a
good
level in the summer but in the spring
we've got to get the fish to breed
if you don't have those guys you've got
a you've got a dead pond we got a dead
pond it was about four or five years ago
it was dead it was down at least a foot
and a half
that's it
thank you very much any questions by
members of the committee
if not thank you very much
seeing no other pink cards
i'll declare
the hearing on 1532
adjourned
now we'll go into
house house bill 1167 establishing a
maximum contaminant level for
perfluorinated chemicals in surface
water
excuse me mr chairman yes
yes um i i'll submit a pink card but if
uh at first i'd like to have permission
to introduce this bill the prime sponsor
had another bill
um that was being heard in another
committee okay and that's uh
okay just uh
okay i'll get a second anyway let me
finish uh
let me yep
don't go away
oh
all right
yeah yeah you can fill that out
once once you've introduced it
all right
so
uh okay
representative
boyd is not here at the moment so
chair will recognize
okay
oh she's sending up a card
thank you
i did i i guess i missed the blue sheet
again
uh if
if
for the uh for the last hearing you
could you just read the blue sheet out
uh for uh
on 1532.
nothing on it very good thank you thank
you i guess i guess we heard everybody
on that
yeah and and also their
their their kids and everybody else uh
okay uh representative rung to uh
[Music]
to introduce the bill well thank you
very much mr chairman and thank you to
members of the resources recreation and
development committee for the record my
name is rosemarie rung and i am a
representative for hillsboro 21 which is
encompasses the town of merrimack
i'm here to introduce
house bill 1167 on behalf of the prime
sponsor representative bill boyd who's
also from hillsborough 21.
unfortunately he um
because of the the the delay in the the
beginning of this hearing he had to
introduce another bill in commerce so i
offered to to sit in and
introduce the bill and address any
questions that you have
okay
any questions of uh
representative rung
i'll wait for uh uh representative boyd
when he comes when he comes i'll
allow him to take uh to
take uh
take a seat great okay thank you very
much
excuse me while i
play with these cards for a second
uh
fortunately uh
i get a lot of opposition to the bill uh
i'm looking for i'm like i'm trying to
find
someone else
besides representative boyd
all right uh
i'm gonna
come here
all right
to where oh there is teddy
representative dears
representative dear excuse me i didn't
didn't mean to insult you that way
i'm humbled
see
don't blame me i didn't put you there
i also brought
i delivered
some letters from other people as well
i am the i'm just the mule
there's another name for mueller
all right are we okay
go right ahead all right
mr chair members of the committee uh
it's a pleasure to be here with you
today my name is ted dears
my name is ted diers and i am the
administrator of the watershed
management bureau at the new hampshire
department of environmental services and
so um
this bill in front of us 1167 this is
1167. we're talking yes yes okay 1167 uh
would add some pfast chemicals as
surface water to uh as mcl's maximum
contaminant levels for drinking water to
our surface water regulations
uh you heard testimony
last week i believe on a bill called
1618 house bill 1618
which would do which would set the mcls
that are discussed in this bill
into the drinking water regulations
and i know that you got testimony on
that and you got testimony on the pfas
aspects of that and the toxicity and the
concentrations and all of that stuff so
i know you heard all of that last week
so i'm not going to go back into that
again today but suffice to say that we
stand i think by the same testimony that
we had last week on 1618 which is in
opposition based on a number of
technical issues which were described
then and are described again in the
letter that that you are about to
receive from me
so i'm not going to spell i'm not gonna
belabor uh the the actual pfast
compounds that i can't pronounce um
but i will
talk mostly just about how these maximum
contaminant levels these mcls
interact with our surface water quality
regulations if they're put in as this
bill would have
us do
so
the way that this works is that we have
a number of different mcls which are
currently
incorporated into our surface water
quality regulations you will find our
surface water quality regulations at env
wq 1700
and there's long lists of chemicals
which are regulated in our surface
waters as well as other things like do
dissolved oxygen and ph and um other
things that we find in the water so
these become essentially the law and the
way that it works is that when we
approve them we also then send them not
onto epa and we ask epa to approve them
and when epa approves them they become
also not only state law but they
essentially become federal law as well
so that's really helpful for a number of
different you know regulatory things
especially things like writing permits
so for people who want to discharge into
the waters of the united states they
have to get a discharge permit
and so epa
uses our water quality standards
to determine how much of whatever
contaminant can be discharged into the
environment
so that's all just going to prelude into
talking a little bit about the
interaction between water quality
standards and how this gets regulated uh
at least by the feds and also
potentially by state
so the way that we used mcls generally
is if we don't have another number
that's in our surface water quality
standards so we will often have an mcl
that comes from the drinking water
program
those are mcl's which were approved
through rules the rule making process
that the drinking water group goes
through
and what we do is that when we go and
review our our rules the 1700 rules
we'll find those mcls we'll come we'll
bring them in
and then they become part of our surface
water regulations
and the important thing to remember is
that they only apply
to waters which are
20 miles
upstream within 20 miles upstream of a
surface water intake
so let's say that again because the mcls
that we adopt into our water quality
standards
apply only to those waters which are 20
miles upstream of surface water intakes
there's a good reason for that the
reason is is because the mcls are based
on drinking water they're based on
people drinking that water so you would
want them to apply to waters that are
potentially going to be drunk drank
drunk
um
so given that that's how these these
gonna apply so i wanted that to be
really clear because if if we talk about
applying these mcl's elsewhere
to other waters waters that are not
sort of
potentially drinking water sources
then
they don't apply there so i just want to
make sure that that's really clear
because it is a subset of the of the
waters of the state which would be
applicable here
it is a significant
subset
uh we know that there are approximately
35 or 32
wastewater treatment plants municipal
wastewater treatment plants which fall
within those that zone
we also know that there's probably 35
municipal dis or industrial discharges
which are permitted that are in that
area that are 20 miles upstream of of
water
intakes so like i said in the past we
have adopted the mcls that come out of
our drinking water program we bring them
into our surface waters they go through
the process they get adopted by epa they
become enforceable law
we are right now as a result of the work
that was done on the mcls for the four
contaminants which you are well well
aware of the four contaminants for which
we already have mcls
we are in the process right now of
writing writing those rules
by april
you all will see well if you're watching
the rule making you'll see an initial
proposal from us which will bring in
those mcls into our surface water
quality standards
and that's the way that we prefer to do
it which is why we're really opposed to
this bill is because we think that the
way that this should work is that that
we should follow that process that
process that we've used for very many
years
to bring mcl's into our surface water
quality standards
and interestingly enough because our
surface water quality standards have a
nexus with federal law with the clean
water act
we also have by law have to review our
laws every three years review our water
quality standards every three years so
we're always looking for what is the new
science what is the new guidance from
the federal government
so these are periodically updated and
will be periodically updated as the
government especially as as epa comes
out with new guidance and we're
expecting guidance on pfas chemicals
within the next couple of years from epa
anyway
and again that's how we normally would
bring these into our water quality
standards again why we think that it's
more appropriate for us to follow that
rule making process rather than having
them put into statute as you see in the
bill before you
finally i think the rule making is uh
and i was having a conversation with
some wastewater treatment plant
operators here out in the hall
that um we want to hear from those
people
and we will do that one of the things
that we will do as part of our
rulemaking making processes we will hold
a special session just for those
permitees who may be impacted by this
rule to be able to give them the
information that they would need in
order to understand what are the
implications of this on their facilities
or their their town or their their
business
so this is another important step that
we will be taking
in in our lead up to rule making on
implementing these mcls
so i'm going to stop there
and open and see if anyone has any
questions this is all a little technical
and certainly the arcane world of water
quality standards is not for the faint
of heart so i appreciate the opportunity
to be before you this afternoon and
happy to answer any questions
any questions by
represent representative creighton
yes sir again thank you so much
not technical at all
is the water we're drinking safe
uh
so that's a great question
and the answer is that where we have
been able to sample
where we have we have sampled for pfas
and surface waters
and we have found certain surface waters
that have high levels of pfas
that is for certain
we have found that most of the waters
especially the waters that are used for
drinking water we have not found high
levels of pfas we have no reason to
believe
that there is a problem with our surface
waters relative to that at this point
that people are drinking
on top of that
remember that these are also mcls these
are already and you've heard this many
many times that the drinking water
suppliers
the people who are supplying water that
is the water that's coming out of taps
in public water supplies
these mcls apply to them
so they can't serve you regardless of
whether that water was contaminated when
it came in from the river
they can't serve you that water
so
so that's the second level
of
of regulation here a protection here so
so there's no reason to believe even if
you did have
say a slightly higher elevated level in
the river and most of the rivers we've
sampled are non-detect for pfas
um
even if you did you still would be it
would be treated before it could go out
to the public does that answer your
question representative yes sir thank
you thank you
any other questions
oh i'm sorry you you have a microphone
you're going to save me hey
chairperson i have a question you have a
question representative cohen first
question thank you for recognizing me
thank you for taking my question so in
this particular bill there are can you
hear me yeah
in this particular bill there are
several new uh pfast chemical
identified right uh some of them right
now do not have mcl levels
with the work you're talking about are
bringing surface water into mco will all
of these be addressed that's a great
question thank you representative cohen
i appreciate that um no we will only be
bringing in the mcls which have already
been adopted through the rulemaking
process through drinking water or in the
case of the four that are in question
here i believe this i believe that there
was statutory language on those as well
but
this would go through
these would be the ones that are already
in mcl already in rule
that we would be applying as surface
water quality standards they are
currently not automatically that
okay
thank you for the clear does that make
sense
can i answer that question
i understand what you're saying i don't
agree that it makes sense for the people
of new hampshire but i do understand
what you're saying right
and i think you saw our testimony on the
other two contaminants as well as
combining
and you know i think
that's what i think you all are going to
be considering yeah okay thank you very
much sure
are you continuing or is this or is that
it
unless you have more questions i'm happy
to go sit uh in the other
seats thank you very much thank you very
much i appreciate it
okay
why don't you keep these uh any on the
next bill
these are on the next
okay
uh
let's see
chair calls uh net grace
thank you mr chair nate grays for the
new hampshire municipal association uh
we do also oppose hb 11 1167 uh for
basically all the same reasons that uh
you've heard um
already today um again we don't
oppose any regulation of pfas chemicals
we're just concerned about the costs um
as mentioned des is very far along in
the process of regulating the
four chemicals that are named in statute
and we would like that process to
continue so they have the opportunity to
talk with municipalities about the
effects
on the municipalities and wastewater
treatment facilities
and consider those in terms of the final
rule making process
that's all i really have to add
thank you
any questions by the way
yes
any questions by anyone on the committee
i see seeing none thank you very much
thank you
uh
boyce
smith boyd smith from
new hampshire wastewater
waters water association
wwa
worldwide and west yeah
thank you chairman uh
oh by the way i do have two cards uh are
you gonna
have two cards here
you just you're just wild with them
cards i i know i only meant to put in
one for this one apologies if i put in
two and i know it's been a long day um
i'll try and try and be uh useful in my
testimony boyd smith the
president and ceo of the new hampshire
water works association and we represent
the public drinking water sector
in the state of across the state of new
hampshire
we oppose this bill mainly on the
process side of things that
mr dears and and mr graves were
referring to
the
the drinking water industry is
absolutely committed to public health uh
and providing safe uh you know
affordable and reliable drinking water
and i understand that pfas are a real
question and an issue for our state
uh we're finding them everywhere there's
certainly hot spots in merrimack and in
portsmouth we all use them and now
they're basically coming back to bite us
in all sorts of uncomfortable places as
we
learn more about how toxic they are
these numbers that we have the mcls that
were established recently are incredibly
low and i put that in my perspective of
working in hazardous waste investigation
and remediation for for decades starting
with the des years ago so we're talking
about incredibly low levels not to say
that they're not
not dangerous but i think i think the
key point is when we establish new mcls
new drinking water standards
it's really worth putting the time in to
use our toxicology and there's
information coming out you know very
almost on a daily basis
to set standards because the standards
then have implications
from the drinking water side and
actually from the customer side there's
big costs involved and you've probably
heard over the last few years what it
costs to up you know grade a system like
merrimack or aquarian or portsmouth to
treat pfas
and
well there's money coming to that and
that's great essentially money that
comes out of our pockets eventually the
other thing that we're learning of
course is the ongoing operation and
maintenance of these systems and uh
we don't know what those numbers are yet
but because pfas is a forever chemical
those numbers are going to be forever
so again our association and our members
are all about treating water and making
it safe i would just say it's very
important to use the you know the
procedure to establish safe limits
before we set them and then incorporate
them into law
um something else i wanted to add a
little bit on we're using mcls and mr
deers talked about using established
mcls
to bring them into surface water
standards but i would say that's a proxy
if you look at and i didn't bring copies
for everybody i didn't think of handing
out copies of the letter i'm sorry i do
have copies of my testimony but if if
you're looking at surface water
standards there's one two three four
five six seven at least seven different
levels that are looked at you know
there's biological standards drinking
direct contact uh
plant standards it's incredibly
complicated um so an mcl is is a proxy
and if you're talking about a surface
water standard it's a really uh even
more detailed rigorous process because
you're looking at health of even beyond
people you're looking at ecological
health so back to
let's
let's use the science to drive the
decisions on this because they have big
implications
um
the
one other thing i wanted to touch on was
there's a piece of reporting and i know
this is fairly standard uh of reporting
the agency reporting back on a piece of
legislation and i understand that
there's a desire uh for accountability
you know and for information on the
result of a new of a new rule
mr dears pointed out that there is a
regular review of epa mcls and other
standards on a on an ongoing basis
and i would
suggest considering
to ease up on
two burdensome a reporting requirement
and i do this i do this on behalf of the
of the professionals that develop the
standards and enforce the standards so i
just wanted to say quickly uh
i've worked for
against and with the nhds over about 35
years
as an employee as on the other side of
the table on has waste site
investigations and more recently in
watershed protection in my current role
i've got enormous respect and admiration
for these professionals as i'm sure you
do too
they work understaffed they work with
fast-moving stuff like pfas and all this
federal money coming our way
and they do it short staffed
and they do it with a
an ethic of service and so i would say
if we can find ways to help them do that
you know letting the processes play out
focusing on what's most important for
the people of new hampshire i think we'd
all be better served so thank you very
much for the time sorry about the second
card i won't use it whatever it says
and i will answer any of your questions
if i if i can
any questions from uh from the board
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you sir
chair recognizes representative boyd
uh if you have them we we
accept all hard copies
uh
maybe
representative dodge might help out
representative boyd
the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman and i
sincerely apologize to the committee i
no problem double booked 1 45 and 2 p.m
it's happened to the best of us well the
worst of us it's still in my first year
uh
new legislature i'm learning about these
these scheduling conflicts
or issues so thank you mr chairman so i
again i certainly through you
uh to my inst to my esteemed colleagues
at the general court
um i come before you asking you to
support house bill 1167
which is a stat which establishes
maximum containment limit for
fluorinated chemicals in surface water
i'm not going to
repeat some of the
things that i talked about last week
because they're all analogous pfas is
pfas
so some of the things that i had talked
about regarding pfas last week are
certainly going to be applicable
um
to to what we're talking about today i
certainly want to acknowledge um
the new hampshire waterworks association
rivers management in des i certainly
read
what they've provided to this committee
and what i would say at the onset
is
should you choose not to move my bill
along
i am open-minded and flexible for
whatever you feel is the appropriate
next step legislatively as it relates to
these six specific compounds
whether it be through study or
through
through other
legislative means i certainly have an op
have an open mind
what i would point out is that
there are 25 states
that have
that have specific standards where they
uh have adopted the apa's lifetime
advisory of 70 parts per trillion
specifically as it relates to people on
phos for groundwater screening
excuse me for ground for for for
drinking water out of those two out of
those 25 there are 13
that have adopted groundwater
screening levels probably the one that
that shocked me was texas
texas has a very comprehensive
um
list of of um perfluorinated
contaminants that they monitor
um
specifically you know
des has talked about the big four fosp
foss pfna and hxs
the two new ones that i'm looking to add
to that are fba and fbs and
texas for
fba it's 71 000 parts per trillion for
fbs it's 3 34 000 parts per trillion as
the standard
for those two particular
surface water containments michigan
washington ohio indiana
also have set specific groundwater
standards not just for
the four that we're talking about but
the two additional uh contaminants that
i want to include
so
as we've identified
um
these specific
contaminants compounds
ch choose your word um they're having uh
in terms of environmental discharges all
we know are having
an impact on on people's on people's
health and obviously having an impact on
on quality of life issues so
the ability to have
a level of these specific particular of
these six specific contaminants
identified in my bill to me
go far go above and beyond what the what
the other states have done as it relates
to establishing groundwater standards
i really believe
that new hampshire has a very unique
opportunity to take the lead in
establishing
we've we've done it for drinking water
let's take the next step and do it for
surface water because today's surface
water is going to be tomorrow's drinking
water um and i think there's a unique
opportunity for for the state to be able
to lead on this particular issue
the last thing that i would point out to
you is a 2019 report done by the state
of new jersey
what they did was they went to 11
warm water
bodies and out of the 11 they analyzed
from out of the 11 they had 14
extraction sites where they looked at a
variety of different
perforal chemicals
not having
established standards for surface water
in new jersey
the reports looked at both both surface
water quality they also analyzed fist
fish tissue um using a contaminant level
of anywhere from a thousand parts per
trillion to two thousand parts per train
out of these 14 sites
six chemicals that are listed in my bill
the parts per trillion range
went anywhere from 1100 parts per
trillion to 10 200 parts per trillion
now i'm kind of simplifying it for the
specific
conversation there's a much more larger
narrative that kind of flushes that out
in more detail but new jersey's begun to
take a look
at at surface water quality as it
relates um as it relates to fulfill
contaminated excuse me
fluorofluorochemicals so if anything the
the new jersey report i think would be
illustrative for new hampshire again to
further build upon
the the lead that we've taken as it
relates to drinking water and actually
have
surface water quality standards that
have some teeth in them so
i will leave it at that again through
you mr chairman to my esteemed
colleagues of the general court thank
you very much for hearing my testimony
thank you very much for reading the bill
and i'd be very gracious to answer any
questions you may have
any questions
representative creighton
yes sir
thank you sir for your testimony and and
for your action to take care of our
surface water and drinking water
we just heard testimony from des
and they're convinced that they have the
systems in place to
identify and to mitigate
the the p-pass going into
service and drinking water
and so my my question is
uh
why is this bill necessary
uh and how does it change the des
position
with regard to that the only thing that
i would change is that it would add fba
and fbs to the equation right now based
on the 2019 report that was issued to
the legislature in 2020 the goal was on
on the for the pfoa pfos
um
hxss and god i'm doing a total point
with all these letters i apologize the
the fourth
the fourth one uh fna excuse me
um so they've identified those four i
think
and and i i read commissioner scott's
letter and i certainly appreciate that
potentially there's a level of
redundancy i guess
my my
suggestion back to you would be to
include those two additional
contaminants as a part as a part of the
study as other states have already
included those
those two other contaminants new
hampshire is only an act of four maybe
let's be proactive on it on our end and
let's look at those other two as a part
of what was enacted and presented to the
legislature back in 2020
thank you for the question i appreciate
it
any other questions
representative huff thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
boyd um
in prior testimony
um a few folks
were opposed
and they were opposed primarily not
because of the idea of what it is that
you're proposing not because of whether
or not they thought it was a good idea
or a bad idea but primarily it seemed to
me because
they want to go through the rule making
process
i think the legislature should make the
rules
i agree so my question is
is
if everybody seems to be on board maybe
you could do this and just uh verify it
that they're on board with what you're
talking about then i don't see what the
problem is that they would have so
candidly and i hope i'm not speaking in
in contempt of my friends in des what
i'm about to say
um
[Music]
in all candor i i did not have any kind
of conversation with des
about this bill outside of
receiving commissioner scott's letter in
some of the things that i've discussed
with um some members of your of your
committee that happened to live in my
community
so
with that being said um
and i've said this previously that
anybody and everybody that works at des
are are nothing less than the consummate
professionals and they've been since
merrimack and litchfield
and londonderry have since we've been
dealing with this issue now for coming
up on close to close to 10 years um
they've been very much engaged
on analyzing the issue and beginning to
[Music]
for the lack of a better word you know
follow the follow the bouncing ball as
to where it goes so
i prefer a legislative solution they
prefer a rulemaking
resolution which again is news to me
at the end of the day
um
all i care about and i mean this
sincerely is being able to go back to
the community of merrimack and being
able to tell representatives from from
amherst and londonderry litchfield that
you know des has added two compounds to
their list that they're going to be
going to be testing for and
to me
solving the problem
is much more important than than how we
get there it's for me and i i say this
respectfully representative i don't care
who gets the credit this is just as long
just as long as the job's getting done
excellent you know to quote belichick do
your job
thank you that's what i want so thank
you
any other
members of the committee have any
questions if not
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you to my colleagues thank you very much
appreciate it
and
chair calls
william howard
wastewa management of new hampshire
you know maybe i'm going to make a rule
that you can't use pofa you have to say
the full names all the time of these
that
then we'll get less of these bills i'll
bet
anyway no i'm not going to do that
that's not i'm not that cruel
mr howard thank you mr chair is yours
good afternoon to members of the
committee i'm here
speaking on behalf of waste management
in new hampshire
in opposition to house bill
there are several
several comments that i have
some of which have been which will serve
to reiterate
uh comments of others that have preceded
me but
nevertheless nevertheless
we would like to put them on the record
one final comment um
which i'll
conclude my comment my uh
my testimony on
i think is is important for
consideration by the community committee
uh relative to um
focusing more attention on
um
public policy relative to
protecting public health human health
and the environment
could you to begin could you pull the
mic a little bit
as has been stated previously ds has
advanced the plan
to develop surface water quality
standards for the same four p fast
uh compounds that it has already
established drinking water mcls and
ambient groundwater quality standards
work has been in progress on these
standards since the legislative
legislature mandated such action in
2018.
the s continues with this work as it has
committed considerable resources
to acquire the necessary background
information to support technically
defensible standards
given the considerable level of effort
that the des has committed to date
and continues to commit to fulfill its
2018 mandate
of house bill 1167
seems to be a premature action at this
at this time
we recommend that the committee consider
allowing the administrative rulemaking
process to proceed
and giving the des the opportunity to
complete its work
under its original mandate by referring
this bill to interim study
and then
as a final concern um
related to the inclusion
specifically of a combined numeric limit
for the six
pfas uh listed in this in this in the
bill
um
i would point out that that such a limit
uh may create the misperception in the
minds
of the general public
that the four pfas mcls already
established by the des
on the basis of an extremely
diligent examination
of the available scientific research
are not adequately protective of human
health and the environment
when in fact the department's
toxicological evaluation determined that
these established limits
do in fact provide adequate protection i
think this is a critical consideration
because
i looked at the bill and i started doing
the math
especially with the first four listed
pfas
and
if you sum any one of those
any pair of those uh four listed
compounds
you could be on the one hand considered
safe
in that they would be they they would
each be below
the currently regulated limit but under
this statute with this uh combined
numeric limit they would all of a sudden
be deemed unsafe and and that
that's going to cause
much confusion and concern among the
general public
so i
i would request that or recommend that
the committee take a serious look at
that and if they have to go back to the
department
and and uh reevaluate that position uh i
would i would so do that in terms of
you know promoting public policy that is
protective of of human health
and clearly understood
to be
protective of human health
with that mr chairman i thank you for
your time and that concludes my comments
any questions by members of the
committee
none thank you very much
that being the last uh first the last
pink card
and not seeing no other and no one's
i'm gonna
declare
hearing on 11
to be
complete
and i will open the hearing on
house bill 1185
relative
relatives to treatment of water
contaminated with perfluorinated
chemicals
okay thank you
chair recognizes the
sponsor of the bill
representative rung
thank you very much uh resources
committee it's nice to be here again
for the record my name is rosemarie rung
i'm a representative from hillsborough
21 which encompasses the town of
merrimack
by now the committee knows a lot about
pfas
don't doubt you could pronounce it
i'm waiting for you to draw the
molecular structures
but
one thing that you're aware of and which
a lot of people in new hampshire become
aware of is
pfas are essentially indestructible
molecules
they
bio accumulate in the environment and
they also bioaccumulate in in human
beings and in other animals
in fact i just sent you a
email with a report from that came out
of des last fall
that
studied
pfas in fish
and six advisories were issued about
that time with do not eat and
lowering the amount of servings of fish
that they get from water bodies and from
surface water so i'll get to that a
little bit more later
but the properties of pfas its
environmental persistence and health
impacts pose problems when it enters
into a wastewater treatment plant
for example in my town of merrimack we
take an industrial waste and we take
inceptage from many local communities
the biosolids we
the biosolid
solids we generate
from treating this waste is composted
and it's sold as a soil amendment for
public parks and other greenways
throughout new england
merrimack generates revenue from the
sale of compost
and this helps us to defray the cost of
our wastewater treatment operations
when pfas enters a wastewater
treatment plant
particularly from industrial or
commercial sources it doesn't break down
we know that
in merrimack it either ends up in our
compost
or in our discharge to the merrimack
river
either way we are spreading pfas
contamination farther and wider into the
environment
hp 1185 would enable wastewater
treatment facilities to control the
amount of pfas discharged into its
facility
and thus control the spread of pfas into
the environment
it would ensure that products of
wastewater treatment facility like our
compost do not compound the problem of
uncontrolled pfas
spreading way beyond its source
i ask that you recommend hp 11 at 1185
for ought to pass
and thank you and i'd be happy to answer
any questions you have
any questions for
for uh
representative
representative post and representative
smith
thank you very much mr chair for taking
my question and thank you for being here
today so my question is if
um
if the wastewater places get to
turn away
where does
where does the contaminants go to
well
i think the first
option that
producers of pfas would have is they'd
have to decrease the amount of pfas
that they generate into wastewater for
example in merrimack
we put a limit from senko bain the
wastewater coming in from saint-cobain
was high and it was contaminating our
compost so
we were able to require saint gobain to
pre-treat their wastewater so they had
to install filtration systems to remove
the pfas before it entered so that is
what i would expect other industrial
manufacturing discharge
um to be
to to have to do is to pre-treat their
their waste waste water
now in merrimack situation and you'll
hear more from the director of our
wastewater treatment plant
um sarita croci she just had to feed the
meter
the
um
cinco bain is challenging our authority
to do that because pfas
and and i think you all got a letter
from
commissioner scott regarding the rsa
that allows municipalities to
regulate the discharge coming into their
wastewater treatment plant
but it's not explicit in statute that
pfas can be would fall under this and
that's the need that's the reason we
have 1185 is to make it explicit in
statute that municipalities are allowed
to regulate pfas coming into wastewater
treatment plants
because presently that's not in statute
anywhere
follow up
so
how
um
difficult question so so what when they
clean it through water a water system
is that then
let out
into the air i know that was one of the
things they were doing to mitigate
pfas right was put it through a water
system
yeah typically um
and especially for industrial
manufacturers that have to
remove pfas from a type of a dischargers
maybe in their process somehow they
usually will pass it through
a granulated activated carbon filter so
it's essentially a big cylinder packed
with granulated activated carbon that
absorbs the the pfas molecules from
what's coming in
and eventually that filter is going to
be saturated and will have to be
removed and replaced
the removal of those that's called gak
filters they'll they go to a special
facility to have the pfas removed um
i don't know exactly for sure but i
would i would guess that um since the
only way to get rid of pfas is to
incinerate it at a very very high
temperature they would expose that
filter to those high temperatures to
remove it
the
the result
the resulting
products of that incineration
would be much smaller molecules the the
the fluorine that's in in a pfast
molecule would be converted to hydrogen
fluoride and and would be discharged
and it would probably go to air
and hopefully there would be a scrubber
system so that we take the hf out of the
um the gas phase of the uh incinerator
and
scrub it through a liquid
that then can be appropriately
um
i don't know why i'm just looking
can be appropriately treated typically
that would result in hydrofluoric acid
yes
thank you mr chair um
actually i believe representative wrong
you already answered my questions um
because i was going to say this is a
may require not a shall require
and you said that saint cobain
argues that merrimack cannot do that and
that's why the reason for the
legislation am i correct
that is true and i'll i'll have ms
crocie speak more to that
but
my understanding is that that
legislation that's currently in in
statute that allows municipalities to
regulate
um things that come into their their
plant
um it doesn't specify pfas and that's
the legal challenge that's being
presented by
saint-gobain great thank you yeah
representative harp for a question
thank you representative for taking my
question
um
as you know being an attorney i look at
these very specifically and did you mean
this statute to cover
uh septic haulers that haul from
residential septic systems not really
miss crotchet can speak more to that but
for instance car washes
often use septic haulers and we find
that there's a lot of pfas in car wash
discharge because of that undercoating
when they say teflon protection
they're spraying the cars with pfas
that liquid is collected and once it's
removed from the site of the car wash
they use a septic hauler the intent is
not to regulate
residential users and typically
residential users are
deceptive is collected from all
residential users it's not
separated i mean it's not combined with
industrial manufacturing septage so
that's that would be the approach that
regulating would apply to septage coming
from um
industrial manufacturer users
follow-up for a follow-up so if this
happened upon you have no objection to a
reference that specifies septic hollers
of industrial or commercial
i i would i would have no uh objection
to that and i think um ms croche can
speak more specifically because
her plant actually accepts all that
acceptance she she she knows what's
coming in directly from septic
okay thank you
anyone else for the question from
the committee
if not thank you very much thank you
very much
now there are
there are
several
co-sponsors
on this bill
who are on this committee
if you wish to speak on it
you have to go to the front and okay
representative cohen you're you're aware
of that okay
thank you
uh the chair recognizes
tracy wood from the new hampshire d.e.s
you have testimony
uh ted dears will be distributing the
the letters to everyone
uh for the record my name is tracy wood
said okay if i remove my mask
i am the administrator of the wastewater
engineering bureau at new hampshire des
thank you for the opportunity to comment
on this bill
so our main point is is that this bill
is duplicative
of legislation that already exists
so we have rsa 149 i
which is sewers and 149 i6 which
specifically talks to bylaws and
ordinances
and this statue
already gives municipalities the
authority to adopt
ordinances and bylaws related to their
wastewater treatment facility
that's required for proper operation and
maintenance and to promote the
objectives of the sewage system
this rsa is broad and it gives
municipalities
the authority to adopt any ordinance
that they deem necessary so in new
hampshire all of our wastewater
treatment facilities do have sewer use
ordinances
we do get receive those and we do look
at them and
give comment and feedback
so this is their mechanism to regulate
anything that comes into their system
this statute
is already in existence so that's our
main point there's already a statute in
existence that gives municipalities the
authority to do this
i'd just like to update everyone
i'm not sure how familiar you are with
nipty's permitting and you may have
heard we're not a delegated state and so
epa region one is the permitting
authority so epa given the fact that we
now have the the four mcls in new
hampshire they're starting to include
those compounds in their nifty's
permitting process and requiring
wastewater treatment facilities to
sample their influent effluent
and their sludge
the influent in effluent is required to
be sampled four times per year once per
quarter and then the sludge is dependent
on how they
get rid of their sludge so if it's it's
based on the volume
so some wastewater treatment facilities
like our legume facilities that don't uh
get rid of their sludge very often they
don't have to report as much and also
included in that is the requirement for
wastewater treatment facilities to
require industrial facilities to
monitor for pfas and that's a once per
year and in the letter you can see all
the different categories that they
require
so that's just kind of some background
on things that are already happening
in the letter we talk about septage
concerns
in new hampshire just for numbers last
year we we had 110 million gallons of
septage go to our wastewater treatment
facilities
the logistics of including septage
haulers in this legislation
is you know most up to dollars they're
mom and pops you know and they they have
the you know one or two trucks they go
they have 3 000 gallon tanks they may do
you know a couple of residential homes
in at one time then they're gonna go to
the wastewater treatment facility and
discharge their load if they have to
hold that while they sample or have to
do some interim have a holding tank like
how would they manage that so i
convey that to all of you to think about
like how would that happen for them how
would they manage that septage and
having to test and the timing of that
so you know consider that in this piece
of legislation
just for numbers we have about 71
nifties permits in the state
of those epa has already required the
pfas monitoring language in
three of them soon to be 35 so we're
already at half of the facilities so
nifty's permits are issued on a
five-year cycle so
a lot of permits already have that in
there um the other thing about the
septic piece is
you know will homeowners if there is an
issue with that will homeowners delay
pumping their tanks will this
legislation you know will they say oh
i'm going to hold off because i'm not
sure what's going to happen with the
pfas
people are very concerned about pfas
right so
am i going to not pump my tank
because i'm not sure what's going to
happen
with the result and are they going to
accept my septage or not right what's
that acceptable level
um so if they have if they pump what are
they going to do with that if they don't
pump you know what's the results of that
they could have failed
failed
system sorry my mouth is so dry failed
systems
and um you know so and how would that if
they failed systems that impacts our
groundwaters of the state so
and then
i think i think that really sums it up i
mean our main concern is really that the
the legislation already exists it's
already in place why do we need
duplicate of duplicative legislation
we already have it they already have
their sewer use ordinances they can
amend those at any time to include any
chemicals they want
the legislation in bra is broad and they
can do any pollutant they choose
so that ends my testimony if anyone has
any questions
representative harp
for a question thank you for taking my
question just a
technical question for the record could
you tell us what nifty stands for
yeah sorry national pollutant discharge
elimination system
it's the the permitting system that
that
permits point source discharges to
surface waters
so any wastewater treatment facility
that has a point source or pipe
discharge to a surface water is
regulated through nipties
thank you
i have a question uh
your statement is that or at least would
your your testimony is that
the law already exists to be able to do
what the bill wants have you had
discussions with the uh bill uh
the bill
sponsors no we have not at this time but
we would like to
okay
thank you
representative smith thank you mr chair
and thank you um
you stated that
um
annual sampling of certain industrial
discharges
happens annually
now is that something that des des goes
out and tests like the car washes
because i've been very concerned about
car washes
what's in the nipty's permits this will
actually require the wastewater
treatment facility to sample them
however
they can also through their sewer use
ordinance require the industry to sample
and provide the samples to them the
sewer use ordinance is a very powerful
mechanism
and it gives like i said the community
the broad authority to adopt anything
that they need they they feel they need
to to protect their infrastructure we
know wastewater infrastructure is very
expensive if you look what portsmouth
just spent on their wastewater treatment
facility over 93 million dollars you
talk about the collection system
you know people are protecting their
investment so thank you
anyone else
seeing no one else thank you very much
chair calls
notch grace
from the new hampshire municipal
association
thank you mr chair nate grace from the
new hampshire municipal association
i actually get to support a pfas bill um
so i'm here to support uh hb1185
uh the way we read this bill is that it
clarifies the authority that
municipalities have
so i don't disagree with des they
already have this authority
um through their sewer use ordinance
but the way that we read it is it just
more clearly states they have this
authority with regard to pfas in
particular as you heard representative
rung state
that has been in contention
in the municipality that she represents
and there has been quite a lot of
litigation about whether or not the
municipality has this authority
and we think it's very important to
clearly spell this out
just to make sure that there is no
question and and that question is not
being decided by someone in a black robe
but it's all of you
and so that
everyone is very clear that the
municipalities do have this authority
as far as the
uh
real purpose of this bill
one of the things that this bill is
going to do is allow waste water
treatment facilities
to
better identify
sources of pfas contamination so
one of the major concerns that we've
heard from our municipalities who have
wastewater treatment facilities
is that they will receive
um
wastewater in all forms
through their sewer system
and
they'll and they'll have their end
products which are the the liquid that's
discharged the river for instance and
then the the compost that is sold
for fertilizer
and that will be tested as sort of a
routine process and they'll find out
there's pfas in it and they don't have
any sort of testing that they're doing
upstream
to figure out where that's coming from
and so they
what this would do is just clarify they
have that they have this authority to go
out and say
hey
you know
we think you might be introducing pfast
the system we want you to test test what
you're putting into the system
um
and in speaking with a
number of people in the hallway here
really the intent is just to have sort
of a random sampling to have a better
idea of where this is coming from we
know things like
car washes are sources because
somebody at some point time said hey we
think this is a source we did a sample
and sure enough pfas came up but of
course there are
thousands of
of different uh
connections to the wastewater system
with
hundreds of thousands of different uh
uses
and we haven't narrowed down where the
pfas is coming from in all instances and
so that's
one of the intents here is try to figure
out where it's coming from
so we can hold the responsible parties
responsible or at least identify who
they are
i'm happy to take questions
go ahead
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
uh testifying uh just a quick question
um
i'm getting the the gist that
from your testimony
that this is to
you agree that the municipalities
already have the the ability to this
would just kind of sort of shore that up
right i'm also getting the sense that
it's to shore up because of whatever
infractions have already happened and
that you want to be able to to possibly
do something about that my question is
is wouldn't that basically be a retro uh
act of law uh and go against our
constitutional article 23 about
no because we're not going back to test
old samples we're talking about
um
about you know current discharges so
this law goes into effect tomorrow
you know company x puts pfas into the
wastewater system they say hey
uh you know we have evidence you're
putting pfast in the system
we want you to test uh company x test
sure enough they're putting b fast in
the system that's not going back in time
we're looking forward okay thank you
thank you
any other questions
seeing no hands
thank you very much thank you
uh
larry masnick
representing masnic septic service
good afternoon my name is larry masnick
co-owner of madison accepted service
with my wife we are
mom-and-pop service
uh thank you for letting me speak
representative ron zulu
um
actually i did make up a
uh a letter i'd like to hand out
you just have one copy
two okay
it just goes basically i'm supposed to
declare
okay i'll read this off that's part of
my
so in lieu of house bill
1185 would enable wastewater treatment
plants to require any industrial or
commercial facility or septic collar
contributing discharge to determine the
level of pfas in the discharge
in the third level it says a wastewater
treatment plant may refuse discharge
from an industrial or commercial
facility or septic hauler that has
reported a level of pfas and its
discharge above the level the wastewater
treatment plant
determines to be acceptable
at present time it is taking two weeks
to get the test back from the labs with
these pfas
with each test costs
over two hundred dollars a hauler would
have to pre-test every tank
they pump two weeks in advance so as not
to get stuck with a hot load
like representative post said what do we
do with it
if the wastewater treatment plant won't
take it what do i do with it
i already took it out of the tank
with the price of the test plus the
labor charge of performing the pre-test
we would be doubling the cost of pumping
pumping for each individual tank
people are already choking on our
thousand we're a thousand gallon tank
we're 290 dollars
we'd be up around upwards around 500
a septic tank
in a septic system just to be short
all it is
is a strainer it's to strain the solids
out of the gray water so just the gray
water mainly is going to the septic
field
if these
like any
filter
if these the more these things get
filled up the more contaminants are
going to get by it
and these these solids get out into the
field and that's the main reason septic
fields fail
because these solids get into the
fissures in the soil they plug them up
the water can't percolate down to these
fissures in the soil
water can't go down it comes up onto the
surface and you have a failed system
these tanks need to be cleaned
periodically to get back the
maximum volume in these tanks to collect
these solids out as best they can
what would we do if there is an
emergency call in a municipality pump
station when the sewage is pouring out
onto the street
take a sample and tell them we'll have
to wait for the test results to come
back in two weeks
i don't think so
and i do we haul also commercial
municipalities and residential
uh yes i do
we take two tanks we're going out to
amherst i'll take two tanks out there if
i have a uh
another commercial site i'll take that
tank and then we'll go dump it and then
we go maybe another direction i have two
trucks that i have running
right now one and during the winter is
our slow time
but like i said representative post says
what do we do with these hut loads where
do we bring them
that is that is my uh rebuttal to this
uh it needs to have more clarification
in this bill before you pass it
and that's all my statement
question for the witness representative
post
again thank you for taking my question
mr chair and thank you for testifying
today could you please send us um to our
emails your your your testimony today
sure yes
um where would i get the emails um so
um
generally just to the legislative email
so
it would be our first name last name
no no no
okay
send it to the uh senator to the
committee the the committee has our
resources recreation development
committee
so it's you should be able to get it off
of the uh
uh
the
website
mr chair
if you go to the general court website
understanding committees it'll give you
our committee designation you can email
all committee or individual members
thank you
any other questions i was on the i i
started uh
with
des back in 2019 we were on a committee
to look into this pfas thing i'm i'm
kind of surprised i it kind of got put
on the back burn and when colbert hit
i'm surprised it just came up this quick
and that kind of caught us off guard i
apologize for that well
put it this way we have a we haven't met
in session all year so
without any other questions thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
uh
okay
[Music]
uh sarita or croche
do you really need 10 to 15 minutes
thank you
thank you mr chair um and members of the
committee i appreciate the opportunity
to testify um i actually did email two
letters to the committee one is from our
town manager um actually i probably
should say my name is sarita croche um i
actually work in a wastewater treatment
plant i run the merrimack wastewater
treatment plant um we are a five mgd
system and we have the privilege of
having a lot of issues with pfas at this
present time and over the past six years
we've had a lot of issues in trying to
deal with it and i'm here today rather
than reading the letter i'd like to tell
you it doesn't work
what's there right now it doesn't work
we have tried to get
one of the industrial users in our
community to
deal with some of the pfas
all we get is legal documents telling us
we don't have the authority so it
doesn't work
we try to sample and it is very
expensive we don't have an unlimited
income
or unlimited budget we have a set budget
and so we also have to be cognizant of
what we're dealing with so it doesn't
work what i put forth in the
letter that was from myself and the dpw
director
i mentioned that we accepted 4.5 million
gallons of septage
last year and the cost of that septage
was 354 thousand dollars we also
accepted
660 tons of
um
sludge
we actually accepted the sludge from
franklin
which
ms wood was talking about so we take
that sludge we process that sludge
that sludge what those communities paid
last year was 393 thousand dollars
now we also generate about 4
tons of sludge ourselves in the town of
merrimack
if we were to try and dispose of that
off site it would cost roughly somewhere
between one and two million dollars
for those eight communities that submit
their
septage to us and those eight
communities that submit give us their
sludge
the cost would astronomically increase
if we can't handle the pfas issue the
reality is is we have a compost facility
and what we do in this compost facility
is we take the sludge we take the
septage we process it through our
wastewater treatment plant we take the
sludge that we generate and we de-water
it and then after we de-water it we take
it we mix it with a
sawdust and we heat it to very high
temperatures so the idea behind that is
you do a pathogen reduction and when you
do that pathogen reduction you kill all
those things that could make anybody
sick and then what we do is we market it
and we're marketing it through a company
called agrisource we were able to market
last year
fifteen thousand cubic yards of our
compost and we were able to give away
750 cubic yards of compost to to the
municipality and local areas our intent
or our belief of this is to help start
the process of trying to figure out
where it's all coming from because the
reality is is when it hits the
wastewater treatment plant that's the
last place there's no place else to turn
there is no technology out there to help
a wastewater treatment plant treat for
pfas it doesn't exist
so the best approach to actually deal
with this is to handle it at the source
level
those industrial users
those commercial users interestingly
everybody's talking about car washes
well we had actually des sampled a car
wash in the town of merrimack there was
no pfas in the wastewater there it was
non-detect so again the importance of
this is understanding where it's from
the intent
from our perspective is not to sample
every load of septage the fact of the
matter is the community in which we run
all of the septic that's generated in
that community has to be accepted by the
municipality so we don't have a choice
so the concept that we wouldn't accept
something from a pump station in the
town of merrimack
because it wasn't sampled is is not
correct we have to accept it
what we would like to see is the ability
to be able to accept each haulers to do
a representative sample so we understand
where it's coming from and we can start
managing the problem because the reality
is as i point out in my letter is that
if we talk about the increase to
people who are trying to pump their
septuage tanks i have a septic tank
personally that it doubles we're talking
about rates in the town of merrimack
quadrupling if you have to now start
disposing of sludge off-site
so it's a very big problem and the first
step in any big problem like this is to
understand it and that's what i believe
this the intent of this was it was to
try and understand what are the sources
where are they coming from and
i can tell you from personal experience
of asking an industry
to sample and to correct some issues all
we got is thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of dollars of legal action
where their lawyers will send us letters
saying that we don't have the legal
authority so even if it just clarifies
the fact that we have the authority to
take care of these issues that would
help us the next the other thing i want
to point out is
uh
what ds was talking about
with regard to the program where we can
require people to sample that's called
the pre-treatment program
40 cfr part 403 the pre-treatment
program has a lot of rules in it and in
those rules they specifically state what
we can and can't regulate it's not as
simple as just adding something to our
sewer use ordinance it has to go to new
to epa for approval it has to go to des
for approval it also has to go to a
public notice so we can't just
arbitrarily add things and say okay we
just want to do this so there's a lot of
stuff here a lot of bureaucracy here
that just isn't working
and that's what we were hoping with this
particular legislation that we could get
something in there that could help us do
our jobs better so that we don't have to
increase the rates
of our customers in the town of
merrimack three and four fold
oh and i'm in support of the bill thank
you
any questions vegan thank you mr chair
hi
thank you for taking my question ma'am
um you talked about agarose source is a
product or a company that you've
partnered with to
market the end product can you be a
little more specific of what the end
product is
that is the compost so that's the sludge
that we mix with sawdust and we put
through an in-vessel composting facility
where we raise the temperature we mix it
and on the other end we get a marketable
product and agrosource is the company
that actually markets it for us
so when you say marketable product sorry
follow up mr chair my apologies
uh what marketing
what to whom what is the product and how
do you
who are there who's a potential client
for it oh excellent question so it's a
class a biosolids it's actually a low
metals biosolid
it goes to golf courses we've actually
sold it to central park it actually
ended up in central park once i think
it's been to a couple of the sports
fields in the area
our product is not used in agriculture
at all
but it's used for top dressing and i
also want to make a point uh this is not
a fertilizer it's an amendment so it's a
it's a material that has a high nutrient
value with a low carbon threshold
in the letter i point out that the
product has a low carbon footprint so
we're all concerned about those
greenhouse gases and ozone and all of
that stuff
this type of approach to managing our
sludge helps lower that greenhouse
footprint it helps bring it down so that
we are not attacking that ozone layer
did i answer your question
yeah you did um
for the record mr chair i'd like to note
that this
topic could be usable in previous
testimony we heard today regarding the
commission
that was a bill uh crawford
uh regarding what to do with
wastewood because she said the magic
word for me which was sawdust
that's why i wanted to ask more about
the product i appreciate your indulging
me and thank you ma'am so much for your
information
thank you
any more questions
representative
thank creighton
ma'am um i appreciate your passionate
and knowledgeable testimony
um i'm trying to connect two dots
uh
if you could just explain further
we had previous testimonies saying that
this is already in legislation
it was already legal
and yet
you have problems with legal aspects of
this can you clarify that for me i i'm
i'm just trying to understand so i
believe what was said is that the rsa
exists where the town or the community
can put it in their what's called a
sewer use ordinance so the sewer use
ordinance is the laws by which the town
and community run their particular
community our sewers use ordinance which
is 158
gives all the rules associated with what
we can and can't do so for example it
sets limits on things like copper lead
or anything like that that's in
wastewater for industrial users
so
the fact that it exists doesn't mean
that it's in place right now so we would
have to put
those regulations in our sewer use
ordinance first and foremost now you
know in when we put it in our sewer use
ordinance there's a process and usually
we have to have a basis for putting it
in so for example um the federal
government says that if you run a
certain type of industry
you can't discharge x y and z above a
certain concentration then what we do is
we go back and say okay
we do what's called a local limit study
we evaluate all that and then we'll come
up with local limits we will submit them
to epa epa will look at them then they
will have a public notice and it will
end up going into our sewer use
ordinance
so all of that doesn't exist right now
as evidenced by all the legal action
that has been taken against us
and
while
i guess it's a
a
discussion of you know
a higher level discussion
what is there right now from a practical
standpoint from the wastewater treatment
plant who's dealing with it
it it's not effective
for a follow-up sir
so
okay understand so it's there but it's
not effective so it's not implementable
how does 1185 help you
in implementation
because it makes it clear
to everyone that the town of merrimack
has the authority the wastewater
treatment plant under their
pre-treatment program has the authority
to go to various commercial
um
and industrial facilities and say to
them you guys do need to go back you do
need to address or sample for pfas
compounds and by the way i'm not
concerned with the four because from a
perspective of
septage uh i mean uh from compost i have
to test for 20 plus
so i have to make sure more than the
four are not in there
it gives us that authority to go back to
them and ask them to give us this
information and hopefully we don't have
to deal with as much legal action
okay thank you man appreciate it
anyone else
representative post thank you very much
mr chairman um
uh someone here previously um testified
he was a septic caller that if he had to
test
and and the problems that
you know
goes with the testing and that he would
have to do it two weeks
you know in advance and the cost and and
then what what would he do with it if he
couldn't
bring it anywhere so that's in the spill
how does that affect you or help you
so um had i what i pointed out earlier
is if we have a
uh customer in the town of merrimack we
can't not accept that septage so that
that issue doesn't exist in terms of the
town of merrimack
um
the
approach and i would be and i would
think this would be a wise decision the
the
interest with septic haulers is
understanding what is coming from septic
haulers so now let's use an example i i
work at a particular facility or i work
at a commercial facility and they
cleaned their floors and they stripped
them and everything went to their septic
tank they went and they pumped it then
they came over and they dumped it in
the wastewater treatment plant the idea
is that you'd be able to sample that not
necessarily that we would reject it
but you'd be able to sample it you'd be
able to figure out what's in there so
that we know as we move forward in this
process of trying to figure out what to
do with all of this stuff how to manage
it
that one car wash that i talked about
that came back non-detect for all these
pfas compounds well wouldn't it be
wonderful if another car wash that had
pfas compounds in it we could have these
guys talk and say hey you may want to
talk to these people because they're
using something that doesn't have pfas
so i think from our perspective it's
that education it's that ability to
figure out where it's all coming from so
that we who manage wastewater treatment
plants who are in the business of making
clean water can do it responsibly and
figure out how we can continue to
make a marketable product like compost
that's a recyclable material that would
be beneficial to the environment
so within their own community absolutely
no i see you i see your question
um i i think a clarification may be
warranted in that regard so the intent
isn't to not accept it's more to figure
out what it is
representative dodge
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
you may have touched on this just a
little bit uh to representative post's
question but um
what happens to the 16 towns that do
send the sludge
if you cannot market it
they have to find a
another outlet for it and so that's what
i was talking about landfilling their
cost would go probably from you know
393 000 which is what those eight
communities are charged by us to in
excess of one or two million dollars a
year so it would be a huge impact to the
communities
thank you
anyone else
seeing that thank you very much
thank you
uh that's the last pink card
so i'll declare
this hearing on house bill
to adjourned
and uh we'll move into house bill
1602 fn relative to perfluorinated
chemicals
in drinking water
okay hello cheer hello champ person and
fellow um committee members it's
chairman chairman sorry chairman
uh i am a co-sponsor of this bill our
prime sponsor
is out with cobit so i'll do my best to
introduce and position this bill
and then after we hear the testimony we
can decide if our next steps is to
workshop it or discuss it at a public
executive session but let me explain the
bill to you right now
this is a bill
that is another one of the bills dealing
with the pfas situation in our state
the type of bills that were we've been
looking at as a committee with pfas
either identify the problem
protect the new hampshire residents from
the problem or remediate the problem
this bill is a bill that falls in the
category of really identification
the sponsors are across state sponsors
including my colleague from merrimack
representative boyd who is a um
by experience an expert in pfas as well
so
one of the things that we received about
this bill
was a letter from the des and i'm hoping
they're here to present today
it's my intent to work with the prime
sponsor of this bill
to position an
amendment to our group to uh our
committee to look at that will address
some of the issues that the um dsds had
brought up they brought up the issue
this this original bill
really uh calls for
testing in a school system everything
the bubblers the sinks everything
um i'm looking at an amendment that
we'll
address that we're just testing at the
source of where this polluted water or
non-polluted water comes in
a second issue
is that it really will not pertain to
schools that are in municipal
water because
schools on municipal water already being
tested for pfas and the third issue that
needs to be addressed is that the size
of the school uh right now schools with
less than 25 people are exempt from this
we probably don't want to exempt anybody
in the protection here
so that's kind of where i that's kind of
where i am with this bill i think des is
here to testify as well and like i say
if this i'll try to answer your
questions on intent of the bill
once we're finished with any testimonies
say we can decide
what our next steps are with the
chairperson workshop public workshop or
just public discussion in our executive
session
so
i'm ready for any questions
mr chairperson
and he
mr chairs he's fine
sir just don't call me late for supper
uh
the uh
any questions from the uh
the speaker
uh
seeing none
and realizing that you're pinch hitting
uh
i think
we'll
let you sit down and uh
have only one
only one card so far
uh
is uh brandon kernan
from new hampshire des
representative cohen could you hand in a
pink card did you or did you
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee i'm brandon kernan i'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater bureau at bes
here to testify on house bill 1602
um as mentioned we
provided a letter
and we'd be happy to work with the
representative on on amendments to the
bill as he alluded to before
i'll be really brief
we support the intent of the bill
identifying exposure to pfas and
drinking water and eliminating it is
important we do believe there's a
more efficient and cost effective way to
achieve that outcome
that would be by first of all as
described previously only test a source
of water not every fixture at each
facility
it was modeled this bill after the lead
legislation where it does make sense to
test every fixture for lead at a school
and child care facility because the
source of contamination can be the
fixture or the local plumbing system
but with pfast although hypothetically
that could be the case we just haven't
seen the plumbing system be a source of
pfas contamination it's generally
environmental contamination
and it's important to distinguish
the difference between testing just a
source in a number of fixtures and some
of these big schools could have 100 120
fixtures if you go to every lab sink
every bathroom kitchens nurses room all
that
and at two to three hundred dollars a
sample that would be very costly and
again i think you could achieve
the same thing by just testing the
source of water
the other thing we're recommending is
that
any school that's a stand-alone public
water system that means they have their
own on-site well and served more than 25
people of
water a day
or anyone or any school a child care
facility that purchases water from a
water system
not be required to do any more testing
because
already public water systems be it if
they're their own public water system or
if they're buying water from a public
water system they've already tested four
times for pfast and now have an ongoing
requirement based on those initial
results that could range from
quarterly to once every three years
we um
do suggest in the letter that there's
that
there's a subgroup of entities out there
that don't have any testing requirement
for pfas right now that would be the
very small child care facilities
and also the schools those that are
serving less than 25 people
obviously it'd be a big
expense for a small
entity to complete the sampling
so one thing we
suggest in our letter is that your des
or health and human services
could potentially sample those entities
health and human services has a grant
with the cdc called shoe safe places
program that works on making sure
environment environments for children
are safe and they are contemplating
doing voluntary sampling
at uh child care facilities that don't
have information on pfas
and similarly des does have a sampling
budget um to identify pfas contamination
and we could assist in the next 18
months with sampling those
schools and child care facilities that
don't have to
sample or don't buy water from a system
that does sample
a little bit of a tricky part of all
this is when you talk about
child care facilities schools and then
public water systems you've got three
different agencies and lists involved
you've got the schools the department of
education
child care facilities is department
health and human services and to the
extent any of those are actually a
public water system you have us
and so when we work this out in a work
group we really want to look at how we
want to administer this if we want to
make it mandatory or voluntary
what is
do you want to go in and work right now
it's in the state drinking water act
which is the es statute do you want to
work in within the rules or regular
statutes of the other programs instead
for the entities that des doesn't
currently regulate those are all things
that we can hash out at a work group
level
i'd be happy to answer any questions
representative smith
thank you mr chair for taking my
question um in the letter uh thank you
for being here today also um in the
letter from uh
commissioner scott he says 50 schools
use on-site private wells
um are these public schools are there
public schools that are not on a
municipal water are these all private
schools
i would have to look at the list it's
possible they could be public schools or
even a preschool associate of the public
school that's in a separate building
than the school itself
thank you
any other questions
i do have
one
one one question uh
if for small
small daycares
maybe they had six kids 10 kids
uh can they simply
say
we only serve bottled water here
is that sufficient you have to test
there well uh if they're serving to
children bottled water
are you using bottled water and cooking
i would defer to health human services
on what their rules allow obviously
bottled water is one way to
eliminate
exposure and at the extent they had that
voluntary sample result they could
choose that simple remedy yeah dhs yep
vhs was yeah there would probably be the
better
better person to question thank you
anyone else
representative creighton
um thank you for your letter thank you
mr chairman
uh if you talk to the sponsors of the
bill regarding your suggestions and what
was their response
we have not talked to the sponsors i've
had trouble reaching representative
grass i've tried on other bills but we
did in the fiscal note outline these
issues
where they asked for technical
concerns or or improvements so hopefully
that did get that's my understanding
that's part of the fiscal notice to get
conveyed back to the sponsor okay thank
you
i will point out there is the fiscal
note attached to the bill because as
proposed it'd be a lot of work to
minister this program yep
there's a fiscal note but i do not
believe it's going on to uh
you know i don't think it's an early
bill
i'm sorry
uh
i don't believe it is an early bill i'd
have to check but
representative yeah thank you mr chair
and um i was just looking at the fiscal
note and you had mentioned that there
could be grants that would cover the
cost of testing is that
i'm not quite sure i heard you correctly
i just wanted to make sure because i'm
looking at the 130 000.
so the fiscal note is based on sampling
every fixture in every child care
facility in every school
and
then it spreads it over five years
for the number of schools
and what we're proposing is we've
identified out of the universe of child
care facilities and schools about 150 of
those two entities all together that may
not be sampling for pfas because they're
not required to because they're not a
public water system and that des or hhs
we both have opportunities to help help
them do voluntary sampling but if they
declined us we wouldn't have authority
necessarily to make them do that
follow-up or follow-up
so the um so if i mean i think the
suggestion of
you know not testing all spots on the in
the school all the fixtures is an
excellent idea so that would lower this
quite a bit correct thank you
representative ghouls for a question
thank you for taking my question and uh
thank you
uh
uh right now for example in merrimack
there's
an area where people have pieces and i
was just tested and i'm on the edge of
but they came into my area to test my
well but
way up all through the state
is there pfas would every place have to
be tested isn't there something like the
merrimack situation in regard to the
whole state
in regard that the uh child care places
could be affected or not affected you
know what i mean
no absolutely
southern new hampshire certainly has a
more substantial pfas problem than the
rest of state but pfas is
pretty much can be anywhere and the only
way to know if you're drinking it or not
is to test your water there's so many
sources i know of a
child care facility off top my head in
moultonborough that um had exceedances
so
certainly you know we have in small
towns like center harbor there's no
obvious source there's a cluster of
wells um so
yeah it can be anywhere but
southern hampshire much more so
anyone else
see no one thank you very much thank you
that is all of the
cards i have on this bill
and
with that
i will
so hb
hearing on hb 1602 fn
is cl is closed
is adjourned
that's it just uh
we to let you know we will we we have
another
hearing next week same same bat time
same bat channel
uh
we
uh the hearing after that we will be
doing
after that we will be doing the uh
we'll start doing some exacting
i'll put that out
which means
before exec there will be caucuses so uh
republicans will get caught we'll be
caucusing eventually
at some point in time before
the uh
the second of february
and i presume the democrats will be
doing the same yeah so mr chair you're
thinking we'll start the executive 10 so
we can caucus at nine and not uh we we
could do that
if that uh
uh if
yes we can we will caucus at 10 if
unless we do have sight unless you want
to do with something earlier with uh
republicans
we will have we will have a
a caucus at nine
but we may have we may have caucuses
before then
oh yeah but we're not going to have exec
till 10. no we will start executing
we will start executing
i think it's the sec it's uh
beware
the second i think it's the second
whatever the uh that when that coming
wednesday after
the 26th
what's the first wednesday in uh
but we'll be executing but there will be
a i will put out a schedule
don't worry
yeah
excuse me mr chair
so the 26th for more hearing
and the second
and the second for exacting
thank you sir
you